Ein wunderschöner Name zum Blue Moon auf Fritz. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, das ist wie immer natürlich das Chaos Radio. Zwei Stunden Sendung zum Thema Internet, Netzkultur, Datenschutz, elektronische Politik und uns in der Mitte zu Gast wie immer, der Chaos Computer Club, heute in Form von Constanze und von Frank. Guten Abend. Chaos Radio 127, eigentlich sollte es heute um die Biometritis gehen, also die biometrische Datenerfassung der Bürger durch den Staat in Form vom elektronischen Reisepass, den es ja schon gibt, und in Form vom elektronischen Personalausweis, der eingeführt werden soll. Der wichtige Datenpunkt oder der wichtige Punkt daran. Tötest du gerade mit, Frank?
Das ist fürchterlich, wir wären ja total zerstochen rausgekommen.
Der wichtige Punkt an diesem Satz, den ich gerade gesprochen habe, war eigentlich, das machen wir ein andermal.
Genau, also wir haben beschlossen, aufgrund der Aktualität der Nachrichtenlage momentan, dass wir das Thema der Sendung ändern und über die Online-Durchsuchung, also den Bundestrojaner reden werden.
Weil die Fingerabdrücke, die rennen uns nicht weg, die kommen zwar ziemlich bald und stetig, aber der Trojaner, der ist ein wichtiges Thema ist.
Also über die Biometrie reden wir in der kommenden Sendung, das ist die Sendung Ende September, bis dahin haben wir dann noch ein bisschen Zeit. Heute geht es wie gesagt um den Bundestrojaner, aber bevor wir uns mit dem Bundestrojaner beschäftigen, der den ganzen Tag durch die Nachrichten geht, vielleicht noch ein ganz kurzes Update aus dem Hause Chaos Computer Club. Es sind ein paar Sachen passiert, die zu besprechen und auszuwerten sind. Zum einen geht es um die Firma mit den Wahlcomputern. Bewege mich da auf ganz dünnem Eis, weil ihr habt dann natürlich viel mehr Ahnung als Icke. Grundsätzlich geht es darum, wenn Wahlen durchgeführt werden, bei denen also abgestimmt werden soll, wer wird der neue Bürgermeister oder wer wird der neue, wer wird die Partei, die im Parlament sitzt oder so, macht man das normalerweise mit einem Zettel und einem Stift. Dann sitzt irgendjemand da, zählt diese Zettel aus, und dann gibt es irgendwann ein Ergebnis. Und es wurde ein Versuch eingeführt, bei dem das Ganze maschinell passieren soll. Und der Chaos Computer Club hat nachgewiesen, dass diese elektronischen Maschinen relativ einfach manipulierbar sind und dass damit diese Wahlen nicht der Wahrheit entsprechen. Hab ich das richtig formuliert?
Ja, so in etwa. Also wir konnten im Prinzip zeigen, dass die Wahlcomputer nicht sicher sind und manipulierbar. Und scheint irgendwie der Zufall da ein bisschen zu helfen, weil vor kurzem ist in Holland, wo der Hersteller dieser Wahlcomputer, nämlich die Firma NEDAP, also eine holländische Firma, da ist ihnen leider ein kleines Unglück passiert und so ein bisschen über 360 dieser Wahlcomputer sind abgebrannt. Die Ursache für diesen Brand ist wohl höhere Gewalt, aber betroffen sind also die Wahlcomputer, die die Stadt Köln hatte. Und jetzt muss ich halt die Stadt Köln gerade überlegen, ob sie 1, 6 Millionen ausgibt, um die wieder zu beschaffen. Oder vielleicht doch lieber mit Papier und Stift wird, denn NEDAP war nicht versichert.
Wir hätten uns eigentlich ein sauberes Ende der Wahlcomputer gewünscht, nämlich einen politischen Beschluss, dass wir das nicht mehr haben wollen, anstelle von so was.
Ja, aber wir hoffen doch sehr, dass sich die Stadt Köln da entscheidet, nicht noch mal diese Wahlcomputer zu kaufen, weil das Verfassungsgericht wird ja demnächst sich dazu äußern.
Und die Dinger sind ja auch teuer und kosten auch Steuern Geld. Okay, das ganz kurz dazu. Zum Zweiten, worüber man natürlich reden muss, ist das Chaos Communication Camp, was gerade wieder stattgefunden hat. Das gibt es nur alle vier Jahre.
Genau.
Und es war gerade in Niederfie... Nee, in Finovod, auf dem Flughafen. Könnt ihr ein ganz kurzes Resümee dazu geben? Alle anderen können sich sicherlich auf der entsprechenden Website informieren.
Es war Wahnsinn, es war groß, es war super, es war bunt. Es war vor allem nachts ein wahnsinniges Erlebnis. Es gab jede Menge Vorträge, es war ein Riesenhappening. Das Wetter war toll überwiegend und ich glaube alle hatten ihren Spaß. Es war ein toller kleiner Sommerurlaub, Mini-Urlaub für alle.
Aber ihr habt nicht nur Mini-Urlaub gemacht, ihr habt doch gearbeitet. Es gibt garantiert eine Zusammenfassung und ein Podcast und Manuskripte und so weiter sofort auf einer Webseite.
Noch nicht, aber wir arbeiten dran und es wird bald so weit sein. Dann haben wir die Videomitschnitte oder Audio-Mitschnitte auch davon online.
Gut, das dann zu finden im Zweifelsfall unter ccc.de oder aber klingelt hier bei Fritz durch. unter fritz.de und wir vermitteln das dann gerne weiter. So, jetzt zum eigentlichen Thema dieser Sendung, was relativ kurzfristig in diese zwei Stunden reingepurzelt ist. Die Geschichte mit dem Bundestrojaner. Es kursiert ja schon eine ganze Weile das Gerücht oder was heißt das Gerücht? Die Überlegungen, dass Vater Staat die Computer von privaten Nutzern ausspioniert, um mögliche Terrorverdächtige zu entdecken und sozusagen im Vorfeld schon die Planung von Taten aufspüren und damit unterbinden zu können.
Ja genau.
Soweit so fromm dieser Gedanke.
Genau, also die Debatte geht eigentlich schon seit Februar, März diesen Jahres, weil der BGH, der Bundesgerichtshof, da entschieden hatte, dass also die Rechtsgrundlage für so eine Online-Durchsuchung fehlt. Und schon kurz vor dem Urteil hat der Bundesinnenministerium angekündigt, okay, dann schaffen wir eben eine Gesetzesgrundlage. Und seitdem ist eigentlich auch der Streit darum, vor allen Dingen zwischen den Regierungsparteien, wie diese Maßnahme vor allen Dingen im Sinne unserer Verfassung eigentlich gestaltet werden kann und ein großer Streit jetzt über viele Wochen schon.
Da das natürlich alles Sachen sind, die zu den Interner des Staates gehören und er sich da äußerst ungern in die Karten gucken lässt, selbstverständlich, ist es umso interessanter und deswegen auch das Thema der heutigen Sendung, was heute durch die Medien ging und was heute im Bundestag und in den unterschiedlichen Ausschüssen diskutiert wurde. Das Bundesinnenministerium hat nämlich mehr oder weniger bestätigt, dass es sowas gibt und es ist ein Schriftstück auf Webseiten veröffentlicht worden, auf zwei Webseiten ganz genau, netzpolitik.org ist eine davon, auf der sehr detailliert diese ganzen Geschichten beschrieben wurden.
Also an sich ist es ja ein Skandal, dass so was im Geheimen diskutiert wird, weil die Frage, ob der Staat das Recht hat, auf unseren Computern rumzuschnüffeln zu Hause, ist eine Sache, die gesamtgesellschaftlich diskutiert werden muss. Die Frage ist eigentlich nicht, welche technischen Details oder wie man es genau macht, ob man jetzt diese Schadsoftware per E-Mail verschickt oder auf einer CD oder bei den Verdächtigen in die Wohnung einbricht und da Software installiert, sondern die Frage ist, generell ist es machbar, ist es vereinbar mit dem Rechtsstaat, den wir haben. Werden da Grundrechte verletzt, kann man sowas akzeptieren. Wenn es um schwere Straftaten, Terrorismus geht, werden möglicherweise noch ganz andere Leute davon betroffen. Und was sind die sonstigen Nebenwirkungen davon?
Ja, deswegen ist auch eigentlich diese Beantwortung von diesem Fragenkatalog der SPD, das sind zwei verschiedene Dokumente, die da jetzt veröffentlicht wurden gestern. Der ist halt sehr interessant, weil da viele Details drinstehen, die vorher so nicht bekannt waren. Wo vorher eigentlich der BKA-Chef Jörg Zierke immer sagte, ja so genau wollen wir da eigentlich nicht drüber reden. Und hier sind einfach mal ganz konkrete Antworten gegeben. Und nachdem wir uns also diese Fragenkatalogen und die Antworten darauf angesehen haben, ist uns klar geworden, dass hier einfach eine große Lücken ganz offensichtlich im Sachverstand des Bundesinnenministeriums bestehen, weil manche Fragen einfach aus technischer Sicht unsinnig beantwortet sind.
Der Hauptpunkt, der heute veröffentlicht wurde, war, dass diese Trojaner-Software, also diese Spionage-Software, nennen wir es mal so James Bond-mäßig, per E-Mails verschickt wird, die unter die Adresse einer anderen Behörde kommen. Also im Detail, ich sitze von meinem Computer und bekomme eine E-Mail von einer Kfz-Zulassungsstelle Schnakenbarken und die sagen mir, ihre Steuerzahlung ist nicht angekommen, bitte füllen sie mal hier Dokumente aus und schicken sie mir das zurück, wo ich als normaler Bürger sage, okay, naja gut, dann mach ich das. Was ich nicht weiß, ist, dass möglicherweise sich da und da diese Trojaner verbirgt. Und das Pikante daran ist, dass dieses eigentliche Sicherheitsgefühl, was ja transportiert werden soll, dass im Vorfeld schon Straftaten vereitelt werden, dass das natürlich noch viel, viel sensibler wird bei jedem, weil ich keiner einzigen Mail mehr traue, die von irgendeiner Behörde kommt.
Oder irgendeiner Software, wie zum Beispiel die Acer Software, die zur Abgabe der elektronischen Steuererklärung notwendig ist.
Die mittlerweile Pflicht ist, genau.
Und natürlich haben sich da ein absolutes Eigentor mitgeschossen, wobei ich ja noch eher die Meinung vertrete, dass das im Prinzip nur Nebelkerzen sind. Das heißt, das BKA und das Innenministerium, die wollen da bewusst verschleiern, ist das also mal, ist das eine E-Mail, die verschickt wird, dann wird mal was auf dem Rechner installiert und dann ist es plötzlich, keine Ahnung, eine CD oder sowas, ein USB-Stick, der im Briefkasten liegt rein zufällig oder eine CD, die mir irgendjemand in die Hand drückt. Da wird aus meiner Sicht bewusst verschleiert, was sie tatsächlich vorhaben, was ich aus deren Sicht auch nachvollziehen kann, dass sie sich da nicht so genau in die Karten gucken lassen wollen. Und es heißt auch bewusst, dass sie unter einem sogenannten informationstechnischen System im Prinzip alles verstehen, was elektronisch ist. Das heißt, das sind also Mobiltelefone, irgendwelche Server im Internet, mein PC, zu Hause, alles Denkbare, was noch kommen kann.
Sogar digitalisierte Anrufbeantworter. Also meint jedes informationstechnische System. Also sie haben mit Absicht nicht einmal den Begriff Computer verwendet, sondern sie sagen ganz genau, dass es da im Prinzip um alle diese technischen Geräte geht.
Das könnte auch ein Wahlcomputer sein. Ne, aber aus meiner Sicht wollen die damit also einfach ein Generalerlaubnis haben, beliebig sich in irgendwelche elektronischen Systeme einhacken zu können, da Dinge zu tun, die manipulieren, ausspäonieren, ausspähen. Es soll also nicht nur um den PC zu Hause gehen, sondern um alles.
Und da waren wir doch schon ein bisschen bestürzt. Und jetzt ist halt noch bekannt geworden im Laufe des Tages, dass dieser sogenannte Bundestrojaner, der jetzt Remote Forensic Software heißt, da haben sie sich so einen schönen, beschönigenden Namen ausgedacht, der natürlich überhaupt nicht, ja, begrifflich nicht wirklich stimmt, weil es geht nicht um eine forensische Software, sondern um ein Spionage-Schadprogramm. Und heute ist eben noch bekannt geworden, dass dieser Bundestrojaner bereits einsatzbereit ist. Entsprechend haben einige Parlamentarier da reagiert und gesagt, okay, dann hat uns der Innenminister belogen, denn in den letzten Wochen hat sowohl er, wie auch der BKA-Chef Zierke immer beteuert, seit der BGH-Beschluss in Kraft getreten ist, würden sie nicht weiterentwickeln an diesem Tool. Und jetzt plötzlich ist er einsatzbereit. Also müssen sie in der Zeit, seit der Einsatz verboten wurde von BGH, einfach weiterentwickelt haben.
Der Chaos Computer Club als quasi expertische Instanz zu diesem Thema ist heute mit Anfragen und Interview-Terminen überhäuft worden. Ihr konntet euch kaum retten vor Anfragen. Deshalb auch in dieser Sendung auch dir der Appell an euch oder das Angebot an euch. Solltet ihr Fragen zu diesem Thema haben, wie auch immer, hier haben wir zwei Stunden Zeit, das Ganze zu diskutieren. Wir werden das Ganze auch im Netz selbstverständlich begleiten. Es gibt hunderte Fragen zu diesem Thema. Zum einen, wie funktioniert das? B natürlich, wie kriege ich mit, dass sowas da ist? C wie kann es sein, dass quasi das Bundesinnenministerium an allen anderen vorbei so ein Ding entwickelt? Bis hin zu, wer entwickelt sowas eigentlich? Werden da irgendwelche Hacker herangesetzt, die sowas machen? Und was kann ich tun, wenn ich sowas nicht haben will? Also wenn ich das schon mal auf meinem Rechner habe oder das Gefühl habe, ich hab sowas, was kann ich tun, wenn ich nicht zu Hause ausspioniert werden möchte? Weil im Moment heißt es ja, dass dieser Bundestrojaner selbst von den gängigen Firewall- und Viren-Scannern und was es da alles gibt, gar nicht erkannt wird, was er am Umkehrschluss auch heißt, dass die ganzen Viren-Scanner-Hersteller und Firewall-Produzenten und so in irgendeiner Form darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt werden müssen, dass es da irgendeine bestimmte Datei gibt, die dann bitte durchzulassen ist.
Nee, eigentlich ist es an dem jetzt an dem Fragen-Katalog...
Warte mal, um mein Monolog zu beenden. Also wenn ihr Fragen habt zum Thema, hier gibt es ein Telefon und da könnt ihr anrufen und das heißt 0331 70 97 110. Die Leitungen sind jetzt offen, so.
Ich wollte im Prinzip nur nochmal konkretisieren, weil in den Fragen, in den Antworten auf die Fragen ist jetzt mal so ein bisschen beschrieben, wie es denn mit den Firewalls und mit den antiviren Software's gehandhabt werden soll und angegeben ist, dass dieses Spionageprogramm diese Software nicht ausschaltet, also sich quasi nicht an irgendwie der Firewall vergreift, sondern ja einfach nur Lücken findet, die von diesen Firewalls nicht entdeckt werden. Also die werden quasi, sie behaupten, sie machen das System nicht unsicher, indem sie zum Beispiel auf dem System installierte Firewalls deaktivieren oder so. Das ist so die Behauptung. Natürlich bei Informatikern und Hackern auch einige dann schmunzeln vor Geruch.
Wobei da dann aber auch klar wird, wie kompliziert dieses Unterfangen ist. Das heißt, wenn ich wirklich von jedem einzelnen Verdächtigen, den ich durchsuchen will, muss ich die gesamte Konfiguration des Rechners, sämtliche Software, die bei ihm läuft. Ich muss wissen genau, welche Versionsstand, welche Software-Stand die Firewall-Software hat. Wenn das letzte Update da war, muss es im Prinzip in meinem Labor reproduzieren. Und dann kann ich anfangen zu testen. Aber das heißt wirklich, dass ich es in jedem Einzelfall immer genau selbst machen muss.
Entsprechend teuer wird die Angelegenheit. Und sie räumen auch durchaus ein, dass es eben für jede einzelne verdächtige Person neu entwickelt wird und entsprechend teuer ist. In dieser kleinen Anfrage, die beantwortet wurde von der Bundesregierung, ist mal so ein Datum, nämlich irgendwie 200.000 Euro. Und die Gemeinde wird es noch eher verniedlichend geschätzt. Das wird deutlich teurer werden.
Es gibt eine Menge Fragen zu diesem Thema. Die können wir in dieser Sendung gerne klären. Der erste am Telefon ist Nils, 15 Jahre alt, aus Pankow. Guten Abend, Nils.
Guten Abend.
Hallo.
Und zwar, wer meine Frage ist, es wird immer gesagt, ja, der wird dann bei terrorverdächtigen Leuten angewandt.
Bist du terrorverdächtig, Nils?
Meine Frage wäre dann, wer entscheidet denn jetzt, ob ich persönlich terrorverdächtig bin und gibt es da irgendeine Grundlage für, steht das irgendwo, welche Voraussetzungen dafür erfüllt sein müssen oder können die einfach bei jedem einfach reingucken und sagen, ja, der kam mir so ein bisschen terrorverdächtig vor, da habe ich einfach mal mit den Treuern eingeschickt. Also, das ist meine Frage.
Gute Frage.
Ja, das ist tatsächlich auch eine Sache der Diskussion im Moment. Das heißt also, welche Hürden müssen gesetzt werden, damit so eine Maßnahme stattfinden kann. Das BKA, der Zirke betont immer, es sind wahnsinnig hohe Hürden und es würde maximal zehnmal im Jahr stattfinden. Das heißt also, da muss dann ein Richter drauf schauen und das darf nur beantragt werden von einem Leiter einer Behörde. Also das wäre in dem Fall Chef des BKA zum Beispiel und muss dann von einem Richter abgesegnet werden. Allerdings muss man auch schauen, wie sich sowas entwickelt. Wir haben es bei den Telefonüberwachungen, also bei den Telefonabhörmaßnahmen, TK-Überwachung, dass wir da also eine ständig steigende Zahl haben von Überwachung, weil einfach das Verfahren, wie ein Richter so eine Abhörmaßnahme anordnen kann oder bestätigen kann, ist ein sehr einfaches. Das heißt, der kriegt da irgendwie so einen Vordruck vorgelegt und muss dann im Prinzip irgendwie nur ankreuzen oder kurz in Unterschrift, ja ja, ist okay. Und wenn er das aber ablehnt, dann muss er erst mal seitenlange Begründungen schreiben, worum er das ablehnt. Und da ist es kein Wunder, dass es natürlich eine ständig steigende Zahl von Telefonüberwachungen gibt, wenn es so einfach ist. Und es gibt auch keine nachträgliche Kontrolle und es gibt auch keine funktionierenden Mechanismen, wie sowas auch von Seiten der Regierung im Nachhinein kontrolliert werden kann.
Aber um die Frage von Nils nochmal zu präzisieren, was macht mich möglicherweise zu einer dieser Personen, bei der eine der 10 bis 15 Durchsuchungen im Jahr stattfinden soll?
Naja, wir haben ja momentan gerade einen sehr aktuellen Fall von dem Soziologen in Berlin, der genau verdächtigt wird, so einer sogenannten militanten Gruppe zu gehören. Da kann man eigentlich sehr deutlich sehen, was einen zum Verdächtigen macht. Weil der Soziologe, dessen Wohnung durchsucht wurde und der verhaftet wurde, der hat eigentlich nur Einzitaten, nämlich wissenschaftliche Papiere geschrieben. Und deshalb wurde er verdächtigt, quasi zu dieser militanten Gruppe zu gehören. Man kann also durchaus momentan in der etwas hysterischen Bewertung, die ja oft jetzt so stattfindet, sehr leicht zu einem Verdächtigen werden. Natürlich muss man immer daran denken, dass man auch dann verdächtig werden kann, wenn man zum Beispiel mit Personen Kontakt hat, über die man vielleicht nicht viel weiß oder die in ihrer Freizeit Dinge tun, von denen man es nicht weiß. Man kann sehr schnell in so einen Raster geraten.
Also gesetzlichen Fall, ich spinne jetzt mal wirklich ein absolut konstruiertes Gerüst zusammen. Ich gehe auf ein Konzert in irgendein besetztes Haus und es spielt irgendeine Band und ich kauf mir danach ein T-Shirt und gehe wieder nach Hause und rede dort mit verschiedenen Leuten. Und irgendwann kommt raus, dass bei diesem Konzert, bei dieser Veranstaltung durchaus auch Leute waren, die bei irgendeiner anderen Veranstaltung waren, mit der ich überhaupt nichts zu tun hab, weil ich hab in den Konzerten eingeguckt, war aber im Endeffekt mit denen Kontakt.
Spätestens, wenn du mal ein Bier getrunken hast, weil du bist mit denen ins Gespräch gekommen, fandet die Musik total toll, und habt noch ein Bier zusammengetrunken, seid dabei vielleicht beobachtet worden, dann kann es auf jeden Fall schon soweit sein.
Also im Prinzip kann man leicht in so ein Raster geraten, muss man leider sagen.
Nils, nicht, dass du heute noch nicht schlafen kannst.
Na ja, meine Mutter, also der ihre beste Freundin, die war Arbeitskollegin von diesem Soziologen.
Ach du Güte.
Gut, wir reden ja jetzt auch im Radio, von daher ist es ja auch schnoß. Aber dein Anruf ist perfekt als Einstieg, weil er natürlich die Grundfrage stellt, die jeder von uns hat, wenn man hört, Bundestrojaner und Rechner werden überwacht usw. usf. Trifft mich das? Und wenn es mich trifft, woher weiß ich, dass es soweit ist? Und wenn ich weiß, dass es soweit ist, wie wäre ich es wieder los, wenn es geht? Das sind ja eigentlich die Grundfragen, die jeden beschäftigen. Weil was heute klar geworden ist, das Ding gibt es und das Ding ist scheinbar einsatzfähig. Und es gibt einen Haufen Sicherheitslücken.
Wobei das mit dem einsatzfähig...
Stand hat in der Zeitung. Also klar, wir würden auch gerne wissen, wenn die einsatzfähig sind, wie die so aussehen. Wir hätten da ganz gerne mal eins. Und deshalb wollen wir natürlich auch alle Hörer auffordern, die einen Bundestrojaner auf ihrem Rechner finden. Die können sich gerne an den Chaos Computer Club wenden und den bei uns abgeben.
Nils, ist deine Frage insofern beantwortet? Freut mich sehr. Ja, berechtigte Frage. Also, was macht mich zum Verdächtigen?
Also es gibt ja diesen beruhigtigen Paragraph 129a. Da geht es ja darum, wer eine terroristische Vereinigung ist. Und wir haben gerade in letzter Zeit gemerkt, dass man da also tatsächlich sehr schnell reinkommen kann. Gerade im Rahmen von den G8-Protestaktionen sind da doch einige Sachen gelaufen. Da war also zum Beispiel eine Maßnahme in Hamburg, wo angeordnet wurde, dass die Post aus bestimmten Bezirken durchsucht wird, geguckt wird, ob da Briefe ohne Absender dabei sind, weil es möglicherweise irgendwelche Bekennerschreiben für Anschläge sein könnten. Also da drehen die Behörden gerade ziemlich frei. Und die Grundrechte bleiben da auf jeden Fall auch auf der Strecke im Moment.
Nun gibt es sicher auch genug Menschen, die jetzt sich zurücklegen und sagen, aber ey, du, ich bin ein unbeschuldener, normaler Bürger. Was soll mich das alles treffen? Ich hab mir nie was zur Schulden kommen lassen und ich werde es auch nicht tun. Also geht mir das einigermaßen an der Tür vorbei.
Das Problem ist, dass man ja gar nicht unschuldig sein muss. Also in dem Moment, wo man politisch aktiv ist, kann man natürlich auch verdächtig werden aus irgendeinem Grund. Und das ist ja gerade unsere Sorge, dass die Leute dann nicht mehr politisch aktiv werden, weil sie glauben, sie könnten dann auch schneller mal verdächtigt werden. Und das ist das große Problem bei diesen ganzen Überwachungsmaßnahmen, die wir bekommen, dass die Leute tendenziell eher sagen, die um Gottes Willen, ich will mit den ganzen Sachen nichts zu tun haben, lasst mich in Ruhe. Nachher kriege ich dann noch so ein Trojaner oder mein Telefon wird abgehört, ich werde hier irgendwie nicht politisch aktiv oder will ja nirgendwo auftauchen und einen Zusammenhang.
Es ist auch eigentlich, muss man vielleicht zusätzlich noch sehen, gerade bei der Online-Durchsuchung wird immer wieder betont und das ist auch an den Fragenkatalogen, die jetzt vorliegen, nochmal zu sehen, dass es vor allen Dingen nicht nur um Ermittlungen geht, sondern es geht auch um präventive Abwehr von Gefahren. Also wo die BKA immer mehr im Vorfeld ermitteln möchte. Und da ist auch nochmal eine große Gefahr, weil wenn man halt in so eine Gefährderdatei kommt, dann hat man halt Probleme, da jemals wieder rauszukommen. Also es geht halt nicht nur um Leute, die sich konkret einer bestimmten Straftat verdächtig machen, sondern auch um präventive Abwehr von tabustischen Verfahren. Und hier muss man schon auch von einem Ideologiewechsel reden. Normalerweise ist die BKA dafür da, Verbrechen, die begangen wurden, aufzuklären. Und hier ist einfach ein neues Dogma, was da jetzt propagiert wurde.
Aber das Argument, ich habe auch das Recht, dass mein Staat mich beschützt in meiner Privatsphäre und in meinem Leben, dass mir nichts passiert, muss ja da auch gelten.
Tja, es ist sehr schade. Klar, der Staat geriert sich jetzt in letzter Zeit besonders als Überwacher mit all den Projekten, über die wir hier ja am Chaosradio schon oft gesprochen haben. Dabei sollte er eigentlich, und wir hätten wirklich gute Gründe bei all den vielen kommerziellen Datensammlern, sollte er nämlich eigentlich uns schützen. Und die Privatheit und die Privatsphäre seiner Bürger beschützen. Stattdessen gerät er sich selbst als Datensammler.
Wobei wir auch nochmal sagen müssen, dass die Liste der Straftaten, sogenannte Katalogstraftaten, Versionen und Überwachungsmaßnahmen nicht nur auf Terrorismus beschränkt ist, sondern da stehen auch ganz andere Sachen drin. Und im Moment ist es gerade aktueller Terrorismus, aber gern wird auch Kinderpornografie rangezogen.
Obwohl, da muss man auch mal sagen, Kinderpornografie ist keine schwerste Straftat nach deutschem Recht. Der Handel mit solchen Bildern ist nicht etwa eine schwere Straftat. Jetzt von einer juristischen Perspektive ist es besonders widerwärtig und eignet sich für die Propaganda. Ist aber eigentlich in diesem Dialog gar nicht drin.
Gut, aber die Liste ist nicht nur auf Terrorismus beschränkt, sondern es gibt noch andere. Und zu befürchten ist natürlich, dass diese Liste auch immer erweitert wird. Und sie ist auch erweitert worden im Rahmen der Antiterrorbefugnisse nach dem 11. September. Und es ist zu befürchten, dass die Liste auch immer länger wird nach unten.
Das Bundesinnenministerium hat heute zugegeben, dass der sogenannte Bundestrojaner per anders benannter Behördenmails an private Mail-Accounts verschickt wird und damit eine Software auf privaten Rechnern installiert, womit quasi der Staat private Rechner und private Systeme ausspionieren und ausgucken kann. Das ist heute bekannt geworden. Es ging durch die Medien, es gab viel Gerede, viele Diskussionen. Der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast heute im Chaos Radio bei Fritz bis Mitternacht. Wir haben noch knapp anderthalb Stunden Zeit, eure Fragen zu beantworten. Da gibt es sicherlich eine ganze Menge. Die nächste kommt aus Strahlsund von Eric. Der hat angerufen 0331 70 97 1 N 0. Nach dem Eric. Kannst du noch ruhig schlafen?
Ja, doch. Also so kann ich noch ruhig schlafen.
Na Gott sei Dank, dann kannst du auch noch frei im Radio sprechen.
Kann ich noch, ja. Gut, nur worüber ich eben sprechen wollte, das ist auch vielleicht das Problem. Gut, wie man es nun eben auch einigen Parteigenossen erklärt, was dann wirklich abgeht. Weil ich bin nämlich selber in der SPD und habe eben gerade mal hier so auch schon auf Kreisebene versucht anzusprechen, eben diese gesamte Sicherheitskonstruktion nach Schäuble, also jetzt mit eben dieser Sammeldaten, doch ja, mit der Sammelspeicherung von Telefondaten und eben auch mit dieser Online-Durchsuchung, wobei da bin ich so doch schon teilweise auf taube Ohren gestoßen.
Hast du denn den Eindruck, sie verstehen die Problematik wenigstens?
Ja nicht. Also ja gut, so teilweise auch vom Alter, ja doch schon in Richtung Sechziger, aber...
Ja, da bist du ja eigentlich als sozusagen Jugendmitglied quasi aufgerufen, all deinen Sachverstand da hinzustellen und ihnen das versuchen zu erklären.
Ja, da ist dann so teilweise das Problem, dass ich eben auch so leicht immer flach gehalten werde. Also sprich so nach dem Motto Jugend, hat keine Ahnung so.
Stellen sie dich auch so ein bisschen als Paranoid hin? Stellen sie dich auch so ein bisschen als Paranoid hin dann?
Nee, das nicht, nur eben eigentlich so die einhellige Meinung war, gibt's doch schon alles. Ja, das ist, das gibt's doch schon lange, da müssen wir uns jetzt nicht irgendwie um die Neuerungen drum fürchten, also was da jetzt irgendwie kommt.
Können wir auch nichts mehr machen, wir lassen einfach alle unsere Wohnungstüren offen und jeder darf rein und raus und gucken, was der ist.
Aber nun ist ja die Haltung der SPD insgesamt zu diesem Thema ja sehr ambivalent. gerade das Justizministerium, das ist ja SPD geführt, wehrt sich ja doch eigentlich recht stark und hat ja auch gute Gründe, weil Brigitte Zypries ja immer mit dem Grundgesetz argumentieren kann. Wie ist da die Debatte in den Ortsvereinen?
Ja gut, da kann ich wirklich bei uns sagen, es findet nicht statt. Also das ist auch das Problem hier. Ich weiß ja nicht, ob ihr euch schon mal diese schöne Liste angeguckt habt von der AG Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Natürlich.
Die haben ja dazu aufgerufen und da könnt ihr auch sehen, Mecklenburg-Vorpommern gibt es bisher nur zwei Namen. Also einmal ich und dann eben noch ein anderer aus Neubrandenburg. Und da ich nun den ganz gut kenne, habe ich den eben auch mal befragt, was seine Beweggründe waren, das zu unterschreiben. Und als Antwort kam, das wurde mir so zugetragen. Also ich könnte jetzt eigentlich noch nicht mal sagen, worum es da konkret geht. Also wenn ich das jetzt irgendwie in der Öffentlichkeit verteidigen müsste, müsste ich mich da erstmal reinlesen.
Also Prinzip vielleicht eine Antwort, die er von der Parteizentrale vorgegeben bekommen hat, aber sich gar nicht inhaltlich groß damit befasst hat.
Ja, na das war eben von den Jusos, dass er eben von den Jusos das so hingereicht bekommen hat, nach dem Motto, oh könnte man unterschreiben. Ja, und dass es dann eben so weniger darum ging, dass er sich eben wirklich dafür engagiert, sondern das eben so heißt, oh ja, hört sich gut an.
Um eine allgemeingültige Floskel unter einer Ausführung zu kleben, lieber Erik, könnte man sagen, Freunde, bevor ihr irgendwas unterschreibt, liest bitte erst mal das Kleingedruckte.
Ganz genau.
Danke dir für deinen Anruf.
Wobei, ich wollte eben noch fragen, was es denn eben auch für Alternativen gibt, eben diesen Bundestrojaner so richtig ausmerzen. Also sprich, dass man gar nicht erst auf den Computer kommt, weil wurde ja eben schon gesagt, dass der Bundestrojaner per gefälschter E-Mail geschickt wird. Aber ist die Lösung einfach nur, diese E-Mails zu löschen oder geht das denn so alles automatisch?
Pass auf, Erik, ich fürchte, die Antwort auf deine Frage dauert ein kleines bisschen länger. Die Frage haben noch mehr Leute. Gib uns bitte die Chance, das nach den Nachrichten zu beantworten, weil die kommen nämlich in zwei Minuten und wir wollen das ungern so zusammendampfen. Da kommen wir auf jeden Fall drauf zurück. Der Chaos Computer Club ist zu Gast im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr könnt hier Fragen stellen zum Thema Bundestrojaner. Es ging heute groß durch die Medien. Das Innenministerium hat mehr oder weniger bestätigt, dass der Bundestrojaner quasi einsatzbereit ist. Und es gibt verschiedenste Details, wie das Ding in der Bevölkerung verteilt werden soll. Es gibt eine Menge Fragen, die sicherlich auch technischer Art sind. Wir versuchen, die alle zu beantworten. Ihr könnt gerne auch euch bei uns ins Fritz-Board klemmen unter fritz.de und dort mit diskutieren. Oder aber auch Mails schicken. Die Adressen findet ihr ebenfalls auf fritz. chaosradio.ccc.de Wir versuchen, das alles in irgendeiner Form zu beantworten. Dort wird alles sehr spannend. Wir machen jetzt erst mal die Nachrichten. Danach geht es weiter im Blumen auf Fritz.
Wir haben eine gute und eine bessere Nachricht. Fritz kommt auf dein Handy. Denn ab sofort sind wir auch über UMTS zu empfangen. Den Player gibt es auf unserer Homepage fritz.de zum Download. Und jetzt die bessere Nachricht. Du kannst zu den ersten gehören, die das völlig kostenlos für uns testen. Zusammen mit Duck, den Handy-Experten, spendiert dir Fritz ein aktuelles UMTS-Handy und eine Datenflatrate mit 6-monatiger Laufzeit. Bewirb dich jetzt auf fritz.de und werde Fritz-Alphatierchen, äh, Tester.
Fritz-Info.
Mit Gérald Fötter-Henrich.
Tausende junge Menschen sind in der griechischen Hauptstadt Athen gegen die Regierung auf die Straße gegangen. Sie hatten sich per SMS verabredet. Die Demonstranten warfen der Regierung vorsichtig nicht gut genug auf die Waldbrandgefahr im Sommer vorbereitet zu haben. Wegen des abflauenden Windes konnten inzwischen die Flammen auf der Halbinsel Peloponnes und auf der Insel Euböa zurückgedrängt werden. Es gibt aber immer noch fast 30 Brände. Trotz aller Kritik aller anderen Parteien besteht die Union auf dem Verbleib der letzten US-Atomwaffen in Deutschland. Man könne nicht vollständig auf die nukleare Abschreckung verzichten, sagte der außenpolitische Sprecher der CDU-CSU-Fraktion von Kläden, dem RBB-Magazin Kontraste. Im rheinland-pfälzischen Düchel sollen noch etwa 20 Nuklearbomben lagern. Der Chaos Computer Club zweifelt am technischen Sachverstand von Bundesinnenminister Schäuble. Es stimme natürlich nicht, dass Trojaner nicht entdeckt werden können, sagte ein Sprecher des Computer Clubs einer Zeitung. Schäuble hatte vorgeschlagen, die Computer von Verdächtigen zu durchsuchen, indem man ihnen ein Trojaner mailt. Der jüngste Gammelfleischskandal in Bayern hätte offenbar viel früher auffallen können. Schon vor zwei Wochen habe ein aufmerksamer Nachbar das Veterinäramt informiert, berichtet das Magazin Zeitspiegel. So wurde der Betrieb aber erst am Freitag kontrolliert. Schlachtabfälle waren auch nach Berlin und Brandenburg gelangt. Im Rückspiel der Champions League Qualifikation hat Werder Bremen bei Dynamo Zagreb 3-2 gewonnen. Damit hat Werder die Champions League Gruppenphase erreicht. Auslosung dazu gibt's morgen. In der Nacht ist es locker bewirkt oder klar und trocken. Es wird wieder ziemlich frisch bei 9 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es erst mal sonnig. Später ziehen von Nordwesten her Regenbolken auf. In der Prignitz und der Uckermark kann es auch ein paar Schauer geben. Es werden 17 bis 20 Grad. Der Verkehr Fritz A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt-Oder. Lkw-Rückstau gibt's zwischen Frankfurt-Oder und der, äh, nee, Frankfurt-Oder-Mitte, ganz genau gesagt. Und der Grenze, ansonsten keine Störungen. Gute Fahrt!
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9, dann fritz rundum bellt sich.
Die 2 Sprechstunden.
Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz, Ausgabe 127, letzter Mittwoch im Monat. Wie immer Zeit fürs Chaos Radio zu Gast vom Chaos Computer Club. Sind heute Konstanze und Frank. Schönen guten Abend. Wir wollten heute eigentlich über was anderes reden, über Biometrie, aber aus aktuellem Anlass haben wir das verschoben. Wir machen das in der Sendung Ende September und reden heute über den Bundestrojaner, weil die Medien sind heute voll. Euch konnte man heute kaum erreichen, weil euch mit Interviewanfragen und speziellen Fragen zum Thema Bundestrojaner überhäuft. Es geht ganz kurz zusammen quasi darum, dass das Bundesinnenministerium geplant hat, private Computer Anschlüsse durch Einschleusung von Trojanern, also von Spionage Software auszuspähen, um Terrorgefahr abzuwehren beziehungsweise Planung von solchen Geschichten im Vorfeld schon aufspülen zu können und damit Sicherheit zu gewährleisten. Und ihr habt unter anderem auch oder könnt ihr belegen oder bestätigen oder erklären, wo die Probleme dabei sind, dass es da Datenlücken gibt und so weiter und so fort. Da gibt es eine Menge Fragen und die können wir mit euch zusammen am Radio klären unter 0331 70 97 110. Eben gerade war Hagen am Telefon aus Stralsund und der wollte zum Beispiel wissen, wenn man so einen Trojaner dann hat, möglicherweise wie wird man den wieder los? Berechtigte Frage.
Naja, die Idee bei dem Trojaner ist, dass er sich automatisch wieder los wird oder automatisch deinstalliert. Das heißt, man muss da eigentlich gar nichts machen. Man muss nur brav seinen Computer durchsuchen lassen, am besten vielleicht einen Kaffee holen in der Zeit und dann wieder kommen und dann ist der Trojaner auch wieder weg.
Aber es macht doch nicht mein E-Mail Programm, macht nicht Hallo hieß der Vater Staat, ich gucke mal auf deiner Festplatte rum und bin in zwei Stunden wieder weg.
Bitte frag nicht. Nee, also natürlich ohne die Meldung. Aber die Idee ist schon, dass sich das automatisch weginstalliert und auch für so Sachen, für so Fälle, falls dann die Internetverbindung zusammenbricht, dann soll sich das dann auch automatisch wieder in Luft auflösen und so was.
Das ist natürlich auch sehr wichtig, denn dieses Entdeckungsrisiko müssen natürlich die Ermittler unter einen Umständen versuchen, zu unterbinden. Daher haben sie in diesem Fragenkatalog ganz deutlich gesagt, dass sich diese Software rückstandslos selbst deinstalliert.
Dieser Fragenkatalog ist heute des Öfteren schonmal zum Thema gekommen. Vielleicht sollten wir darauf auch noch mal eingehen, was das für ein Fragenkatalog ist, der heute für so viel Wirbel sorgt.
Ich muss noch kurz loslösen. Ein kleiner Trick ist natürlich, also das BKA stellt sich vor, dass sich dieser Trojaner nach einer bestimmten Zeit auch automatisch wieder deinstalliert. Und man könnte ja einfach die Uhr von dem Rechner dann vorstellen um eine Woche und dann denkt er, ups, jetzt ist meine Zeit hier vorbei und der installiert sich wieder. Aber das ist nur eine rein theoretische Überlegung, aber eigentlich ein ganz lustiger Gedanke.
Ja, also zu diesen Fragenkatalogen. Also eigentlich hat die SPD diese Fragen formuliert und sind sehr umfängliche Fragenkataloge, wo eigentlich tatsächlich der Finger in die Wunde gelegt wird. Also alle juristisch und technisch strittigen Fragen sind da angesprochen, muss man schon sagen. Sicherlich manche Details sind nicht beantwortet worden, aber viele Details, also mehr als vorher bekannt war.
Und der Wirbel, weswegen es heute diesen Wirbel gab, ist, dass es ein Papier gab, was sozusagen von der Opposition an die Regierung gestellt wurde. Und dieses Papier ist heute öffentlich geworden.
Nein, es war tatsächlich innerhalb der Regierungskoalition, nämlich von der SPD. Genau, also innerhalb, die streiten sich ja innerhalb der, wir haben ja nicht so wirklich eine Opposition gerade.
Ja, okay, gut, nehme ich jetzt natürlich zurück, ja klar.
Genau, also einfach, weil die SPD hatte erst mal noch Klärungsbedarf. Und das natürliche Bedürfnis eigentlich, wie der Bürger auch, hat nämlich, dass wir erst mal wissen wollen, was ist da eigentlich technisch geplant. Und man auch bei einem, also nachher durch die Juristen zum Beispiel einschätzen lassen kann, inwieweit diese Maßnahme verfassungskonform ist. Wir haben ja ohnehin jetzt im Herbst bereits die Anhörung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, weil da ist ja eine Klage anhängig, weil es in Nordrhein-Westfalen ja bereits eine gesetzliche Grundlage gibt, nämlich für den nordrhein-westfälischen Verfassungsschutz. Und daher wird es ohnehin höchstrechterlich geklärt werden. Und wenn man sich die juristische Lektüre momentan ansieht, ja, da sieht ja der BKA ziemlich, also nicht so gut aus, weil anzunehmen ist, dass das Verfassungsgericht hier zugunsten der Bürger entscheiden wird. Und hier geht es um Fragen der informationellen Selbstbestimmung, also Artikel 1 und 2 der Verfassung, aber auch um Fragen der Unverletzlichkeit der Wohnung, weil eben auch debattiert wird, wenn der Rechner in der Wohnung steht, dann wird er zum Beispiel vergleichbar mit einer Beschlagnahme von einem Tagebuch oder so. Also die Debatte unter den Juristen wird auch sehr kräftig geführt gerade.
Dazu passt die Frage von Hagen, der die uns gestellt hat, der wissen wollte, wenn so ein Trojaner sozusagen schon mal auf meinem System, auf meinem Rechner installiert ist, inwieweit besteht dann auch die Gefahr, dass nicht nur möglicherweise also in Verbindung mit Straftat stehende Dateien oder Geschichten ausspioniert und ausgekundigert werden, sondern dass da auch gleich mal irgendwie meine private Fotosammlung vom letzten Urlaub mit durchgeguckt wird, dass alle E-Mails gelesen werden. Wem hab ich was geschickt, wer hat mir E-Mails geschickt, wo habe ich das letzte Mal irgendwo mir ein Update für irgendein Computerspiel runtergezogen und hab ich für dieses Spiel eigentlich auch eine Berechtigung, das zu spielen.
Also es ist natürlich völliger Blödsinn anzunehmen, dass man mit so einer Spionage-Software ganz gezielt nach einzelnen Dateien suchen könnte, vor allem wenn das Ganze sozusagen offline passieren soll. Das heißt also, wenn nicht dauernde Internetverbindungen ist, man quasi nicht interaktiv mit diesem Programm arbeiten kann, sondern immer sagen muss, ok, jetzt such mal dies und guck mal danach und dann übertragen wir die ganzen Daten und schauen mal, was wir da gekriegt haben. Das ist so ein bisschen im Trüben fischen.
Schleppnetz.
Ja, selbst wenn ich sag, ok, such mal nach den Dateiendungen oder such mal nach den Dateinamen. Ich vergleiche das mal so ein bisschen, es gibt bei dem großen Lauschangriff, das ist also die Wohnraumüberwachung, die große mit auch Kameras und Mikrofonen, immer diese Sache, ok, wenn was im Schlafzimmer stattfindet, dann geht man davon aus, dass es so dieser Kernbereich, diese gestützten Privatsphäre ist. Also im Schlafzimmer passieren halt wirklich sehr private Sachen. Dann sagen, da muss dann das Band abgeschaltet werden, da müssen die Ermittler dann weghören. Sagen natürlich, naja, gut, dann gehen halt die Terrorverdächtigen ins Schlafzimmer und bereiten da ihren Terrorplan vor. Genauso kann man aber auch Sex in der Küche haben, was dann eben nicht mehr diesen Kernbereich der schönsten Lebensgestaltung ist. Und genauso ist es unmöglich, sagen, okay, nach der Dateiendung suchen wir jetzt oder nach einem bestimmten Textinhalt oder so was suchen wir jetzt nach Stichwort.
Also da gibt es sogar eine sehr konkrete Antwort in diesem Fragenkatalog. Also weil ja in dem neuen BKA-Gesetz im Paragraph 20K, wenn es jemand mal nachlesen will, da ist nämlich genau dieser Suchbegriff erwähnt. Und die SPD hat also nachher gefragt, was ist eigentlich mit diesen Suchbegriffen gemeint, die da im Gesetz jetzt referenziert sind? Und die Antwort ist, dass es zum einen Dateinamen sind, also die Namen der verschiedenen Files, dann bestimmte Dateiendungen, also man weiß ja hinter den Dateien, was da so dran steht, Punkt PDF oder Punkt doc oder Punkt HTML.
Auf dem PC zumindest.
Dann Attribute und Eigenschaften von diesen Daten, aber auch Schlüsselwörter, das heißt, man sucht die gesamte Festplatte nach einem Schlüsselwort ab. Und bestimmte Verzeichnisse, also ganze kleine Ordner, die man halt nach einem Namen durchsuchen kann. Also das alles ist gemeint. Und dann steht noch so ein Satz drunter, dass im Vorfeld ja bereits die relevanten Begriffe für diese Suche ermittelt werden.
Das heißt, sie gucken vorher schon mal nach, was da drauf ist und fangen dann an zu suchen?
Naja, man muss sich ja natürlich vorstellen, dass die Verdächtigen wirklich im Vorfeld schon auch spioniert werden über andere Überwachungsmaßnahmen. Sie müssen ja eh vieles wissen über dieses Computersystem, sonst können sie ja nicht diese Schadsoftware adäquat bauen.
Was auch zu der Frage von, ich glaube, das war Florian vorhin erzählte, der fragte, was macht mich eigentlich zu einem Verdächtigen? Also das gehört dann irgendwie alles dazu.
Wir haben von Matthias per E-Mail eine Mail bekommen, der noch einen ganz interessanten Widerspruch in den Antworten auch gefunden hat, wo sie sagen, ok, das Bundeskriminalamt sagt jetzt, es muss jedes Mal individuell eine neue Software gemacht werden. Andererseits heißt es, die ist jetzt aber fertig. Das ist ja eigentlich ein Widerspruch in sich.
Also nun muss man sagen, dass in diesem Fragenkatalog nicht davon die Rede ist, dass das fertig ist. Das war heute eine Zeitungsmeldung. Hier steht lediglich drin, dass sie ein Proof of Concept haben. Also ein Beweis dafür, dass das erst mal funktioniert. Also das kommt nicht tatsächlich in diesem Fragenkatalog, es war halt aber in vielen Zeitungsmeldungen. Bisher ist ja auch noch kein Dementi von unserem Bundesinnenminister zu hören.
Ihr seht, es gibt viele Fragen. Ihr könnt die stellen, 0331 70 97 110. Wie zum Beispiel Christian aus Berlin, 29 Jahre alt. Hallo Christian.
Ja hallo.
Ich hoffe, dass ich, wenn ich dein Alter und sage, wo du herkommst, dass es nicht zu viel Preisgabe deiner Privatsphäre ist.
Ja, weil ich kein Problem ist, ja.
Allklar. Was ist deine Frage?
Ja, was heißt eine Frage? Ich wollte euch erstmal aufmerksam machen, dass der Elektronische Geheimdienst, die USA, die NSA, die National Security Agency, dass der in Deutschland und auch in Europa jeden Tag tausendfach den E-Mail-Verkehr abhört und dass das überhaupt nicht so richtig in der öffentlichen Diskussion ist. Das finde ich einfach eine Sauerei. Der hat überhaupt nicht das Recht dazu.
Das macht nicht nur die NSA, auch Google liest deine Mails für mehrere Wochen erstmal.
Der überwacht auch den Fax- und Fernmeldeverkehr und das ist alles grundgesetzfähig. Aber das wird nie von den im Bundestag vertretenen Parteien irgendwie so thematisiert.
Das Grundgesetz geht ja nicht in den USA.
Ja, ja, also dieses sogenannte Echelonsystem ist eigentlich jetzt seit einigen Jahren quasi offiziell bekannt. Vorher wart ihr immer so ein bisschen abgestritten. Natürlich, und wir haben ja aktuell auch die Debatte um diese chinesischen Trojaner, die die bis ins Bundeskanzleramt und andere Ministerien geschafft haben. Es ist schon klar, dass ausländische Staaten bei uns massiv Wirtschaftsspionage, auch elektronischerweise, durchführen. Das ist keine Frage. Die NSA, als der zuständige Geheimdienst in den USA, sind da aktiv dabei. Das ist durchaus so, dass sich da unsere Bundesregierung nicht sehr kritisch äußert über das Echelonsystem.
Aber die größte Sache heute ist auch, dass die in Bad Eibling so eine riesen Abwehrstation haben. Von dem aus sie das auch machen.
Nee, das ist mittlerweile umgezogen. Das ist nicht mehr in Bad Eibling. Aber es gibt in Deutschland immer noch eine große Echelonstation.
Aber die gibt es noch, diese Überwachungsstation?
Ja, die sind umgezogen mit ihren großen Radomen. Die sind nicht mehr in Bad Eibling.
Diese Radarstation, da haben sie geschlossen, diese Überwachungsstation.
Die muss an die Bundeswehr übergeben, ne?
Ja, das Gebiet ist immer noch, das Gelände ist zwar immer noch gesperrt. Man kommt da nicht hin, aber sie haben einfach nur den Standort gewechselt innerhalb von Deutschland.
Na gut, aber ich meine, das finde ich einfach eine Sauerei. Ich meine, wenn ich da jedes sagen hätte in Deutschland, ich wollte die sofort schließen.
Es ist halt einfach so, dass die USA sagen, diese Form von Wirtschaftsspionage ist für uns ein politisches Ziel. Denn wir wollen unsere eigene Wirtschaft unterstützen. Und deshalb spionieren wir im Ausland. Das ist einfach eine Frage der politischen Willensbildung dort.
Ja, aber nicht von deutschem Boden aus. Ich meine, gut, wenn die das von den USA machen, aber doch nicht von deutschem Boden aus. Das finde ich irgendwie paradox.
Wir machen es aber einfach.
Wir spionieren ja auch deutsche Industriebetriebe aus. Das machen sie ja jetzt nicht nur gegen sogenannte Schorkenstaaten oder Staaten, mit denen sie nicht gute politische Beziehungen haben. Das machen die auch gegen Deutsche und gegen auch sogenannte Verbündete.
Natürlich, das ist wirklich seit längerem bekannt. Es gibt ja auch dicke Bücher, die man dazu lesen kann. Mittlerweile ist das ja auch quasi offiziell. Also Echelon wird ja nicht mehr bestritten. Aber nun, sie machen es einfach, because we can.
Und und Bad Eiblings? Das ist ja total, da gibt es überhaupt nichts mehr. Nee, ist total geschlossen.
Das gehört jetzt, ich habe es gerade nachgeschaut. Das ist jetzt die sogenannte Fernmelde-Weitverkehrsstelle der Bundeswehr. Und es gehört dem nach Bundesnachrichtendienst.
Hat man zum Beispiel in den Medien hier, Frau Volker-Maser, die Medien hat man überhaupt nichts gehört von.
Oh, das ist jetzt schon, glaube ich, anderthalb oder zwei Jahre mindestens.
Ja, das hätte ich aber wissen müssen. Das wundert mich. Das haben sie wieder anscheinend so geschickt und dann drückt in den Medien.
Naja, oder es war genau der eine Artikel, den du überlesen hast.
Nee, nee, so etwas entfällt mir nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja sehr interessiert.
Man kann halt nicht sagen, dass sie von deutschem Boden aus spionieren. Diese Gebiete sind exterritorial, genau wie Botschaften.
Naja, Moment, aber das ist schon ein Unterschied. Man sollte bedenken, jetzt ist schon der Krieg im 62 Grad vorbei. Ich finde, da sollte man immer überlegen, die US-Militärs hier aufs Deutschland langsam auszuschmeißen.
Das sind doch aber unsere Freunde.
Meine nicht, ja. Und ich hoffe, deine auch nicht.
Naja, wir müssen uns klarmachen, dass alle großen Wirtschaftsnationen auch auf deutschem Gebiet Wirtschaftsspionage betreiben.
Ich muss noch mal für die Chinesen kurz die Bresche springen. Ich glaube nicht, dass es ein gezielter Angriff ist, der chinesischen Regierung oder von irgendwelchen Geheimdiensten. Sondern es sind wahrscheinlich ganz einfach irgendwelche Spammer, die irgendwelche chinesischen Rechner gekapert haben. Und dementsprechend kamen die Verbindungen dann aus China.
Aber Frau Merkel hat es doch gerade in China mal offiziell angesprochen. Vielleicht waren es ja doch chinesische Trojaner.
Es war bestimmt auch nur das BKA, die mal ihre online Trojaner, ihre Bundestrojaner getestet haben.
Ob jetzt chinesische Trojaner oder amerikanische Abwehrstation. Das führt jetzt ein bisschen weg vom Thema Bundestrojaner, wo wir eigentlich hin wollten. Christian, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf. Die Leitungen sind extrem voll.
Wo ist jetzt diese neue Spionagezentrale? Wo ist denn die jetzt in Deutschland?
In der Nähe von Frankfurt.
Guck mal auf Wikipedia unter Bad Eibling.
0331 70 97 110. Wir reden mit dem Chaos Computer Club über den Bundestrojaner. Der nächste am Telefon ist... Oh, jetzt habe ich mir rausgekloppt. Frank aus Berlin. Tut mir leid. Frank, ruf mal bitte nochmal an. 0331 77 97 110. Und dann ist Markus der nächste. Frank, sorry, ruf nochmal an. Hallo, Markus. Von wo rufst du an?
Ich ruf aus Berlin an Fridishein.
Alles klar.
Deine Fragen. Ich hatte vorhin zwei Fragen. Ich glaube, die sind jetzt ein bisschen gewachsen. Aber ich probiere es mal kurz zu fassen. Ich komme aus der Richtung Gewerbe und Unternehmen. Also wir sind um Vertrieb tätig. Und schützen eigentlich als Aufgabe kleine mittelständische Unternehmen. Und ich denke, da sind ein paar Punkte ganz interessant. Das heißt, nicht nur die privaten Rechner sind immer im Fokus. Sondern dadurch, dass man ja nicht wirklich über das Netz weiß, ich glaube, das weiß jeder, der sich damit beschäftigt, wo so eine Kiste steht, oder ob es überhaupt eine reale oder eine virtuelle Maschine ist, ist auch die Frage, wie wollen sie überhaupt gucken, dass es privat ist. Wir haben eine Menge kleine mittelständische Gewerbe, die dann möglicherweise ins Fadenkreuz kommen können. Und was mich auch wundert ist, dass man da die Trennung so sauber hinbekommen will oder soll. Eine Menge Unternehmensdaten sind, die dann wirklich da gelesen werden können.
Ja, also auch in diese Richtung gehen die Fragen, die die SPD da formuliert hat. Also durchaus auch hier ist schon der Finger in die Wunde gelegt worden. Aber die Antworten darauf sind relativ schwammig. Hier wird zum Beispiel auch die Frage gestellt, ob man, wenn man quasi von einer Firma betroffen ist, eventuell Schadensersatzforderungen später gegen die Ermittler versuchen kann durchzukriegen. Wenn andere Dritte das Sicherheitsloch ausgenutzt haben, solche Fragen sind da durchaus auch für die Wirtschaft interessant. Hier hat sich aber einfach, das Bundesinnenministerium hat da nicht viele konkrete Angaben gemacht. Sie haben schlicht gesagt, also sie gehen davon aus, dass Schadensersatzforderungen oder so nicht vorkommen werden. Sie sagen ja sowieso, ihr Bundestrojaner ist das ultimative Späprogramm und sie würden da auch keine Fehler machen. Man muss schon sagen, dass der ganze Frankalok schon eine gewisse Arroganz rüberbringt nach dem Motto, wir können es halt. Und der Zitat daraus ist schlicht, wir haben genügend Sachverstand.
Das sind ja nur unsere Steuergelder, denke ich mal. Vor allem der Knackpunkt ist ja auch, da fallen mir sofort die Provider wieder ein, die ja eine Menge mitloggen müssen, über, ich weiß nicht, sind es jetzt Jahre mittlerweile. Eigentlich so, dass jeder schon Daten vorliegen hat und sind ja auch angeblich keine Kosten für den Provider, die dann auffallen.
Bisher wird immer noch die Debatte um sechs Monate geführt, aber es gibt schon die Forderung aus dem Bundesrat, diese Speicherdauer auf 12 Monate zu erhöhen. Und selbstverständlich werden die Provider die Kosten dafür an uns weitergeben, also an uns Kunden.
Ja klar, meine Frau im Staat bekommen sie die nicht. Vor allem sind neben den Unternehmen, oh schön, dass ich hier unterbreche, neben den Unternehmen sind ja noch drei andere Gruppen, die mindestens eingefallen sind, was auch in der Presse viel war. Ärzte, Rechtsanwälte, Journalisten.
Also alle, die mit einem Datengeheimnis sind.
Seelsorger, Pfarrer, Leute, die anonyme Telefonseelsorge machen, all solche Leute natürlich.
Da stellt sich auch die Frage, wo lang denken wir? Denken wir Demokratie, Schäuble beschließt nach unten auf die Bürger? Oder andersrum, die Bürger nach oben, wie eine Demokratie, zu dem verantworte ich eine Schäuble?
Oder fühlt man sich als Bürger verdächtig? Oder lebt man hier frei?
Die Frage ist auch, muss ich mir zum Kopf machen, ob ich verdächtig bin? Oder denke ich einfach mal anders und sage, wieso? Ich möchte politisch aktiv sein, und dann kann ich mir seinen Kopf machen, ob ich überwacht werde oder nicht. Ja, darum geht's. Leitet gleich eine in die nächste Sache, und zwar politische Aktivität. Also abgesehen davon, dass ich nicht wirklich viel Zeit habe, neben der Arbeit mich da irgendwo an der Arbeit noch zu betätigen, denke ich mal gibt es eine Menge private, eine Menge Angestellte, was auch immer, die das interessiert, aber die Frage ist auch, wie kann man? Also man hat das Gefühl, man kann nicht wirklich was aus...
Oh doch, man kann, wir haben da nämlich eine Top-Idee. Nein, wir haben da nämlich gerade aufgerufen zu einer Demo. Wir wollen mal sehen, wie viele Leute wir tatsächlich auf die Straße kriegen, weil wir denken, dass es jetzt immer mehr Bürger sind, die sich gegen diese massive Überwachung wehren. Sieht man auch daran, wie viele Leute uns schon mal so anrufen im Club und irgendwie Fragen stellen. Deswegen gibt es in Berlin am 22. September eine Demo gegen diesen Überwachungswahn und wir wollen halt alle tatsächlich mal auf die Straße holen, damit unser Innenminister auch mal sieht, dass die Bürger nicht einverstanden sind mit dieser Überwachungspolitik. Also 22. September. Wir wollen echt mal Leute auf die Straße holen und damit die mal ihrer Meinung Ausdruck verleihen.
Vor allem, ich finde es gut, dass ihr zumindest vor ein paar Jahren, ich glaube ich habe es nicht 13, 8 vollzogen, die Wende geschafft habt von einem kleinen Hackerverein oder Underground, was auch immer, immer mehr zur politischen Arbeit zu kommen. Ich finde das super wichtig so was. Weil gerade da müsste eigentlich dann Vereine, was ich rechtsanwälte, euer Verein, was auch immer, dann Hand in Hand greifen, weil sonst du kommst da auf die Basis gar nicht. Ich weiß ja die Anzahl der Leute, die sich dagegen stemmen können überhaupt.
Ja danke.
Markus, ich glaube deine Worte fallen hier gerade auf extrem fruchtbaren Boden, aber auch da läuft ein bisschen die Zeit weg, weil die Leitungen sind extrem voll.
Aber danke für deine Frage und komm zur Demo.
Ja, geht bitte noch nachher ein bisschen auf den Schutz mit virtuellen Maschinen und so weiter ein, was glaube ich für ein Einternwender sehr kompliziert sein dürfte, aber ich denke mal der einzige Schutz dann fast ist.
Im Zweifelsfall, kannst du deine Fragen, sollten sie sehr detailliert sein, auch gerne mailen an chaosradio.ccc.de und auch da wird dir weitergeholfen.
Also konkret ist die Virtualisierung hier nicht angesprochen.
Ich hätte ja ganz kurz für Ortonormalverbraucher erklären, virtuelle Maschinen, richtige Maschinen, worüber reden wir da?
Ach nein, vielleicht sollten wir diese speziellen Detailfragen doch bei mir klären, oder?
Also ganz kurz, eine virtuelle Maschine ist im Prinzip ein Stück Software, womit ich quasi wie so eine Sandkiste, also einen abgeschlossenen Bereich auf meinem Rechner schaffen kann, wo ich dann zum Beispiel ein zweites Betriebssystem starten kann. Und die Idee ist, dass das wie so ein zweiter PC bei mir auf dem Rechner ist, wie ein komplett zweiter PC, den ich auch ein- und ausschalten kann und so was.
Okay, wer es bis hier nicht verstanden hat, muss nochmal Informatik-Grundkurs machen. Das führt aber alles viel zu weit, weil wir sind im Chaosradio auf Fritz. 0331 70 97 110 ist unsere Telefonnummer. Wir reden über den Bundestrojaner. Der Chaos Computer Club ist hier bei uns zu Gast in Form von Constanze und von Frank. Und der nächste am Telefon ist der andere Frank, den ich vorhin rausgeschmissen habe. Es tut mir leid. Kannst du mir verzeihen, Frank? So, deine Frage.
Ja, also mal qualitativ diese Trojaner-Geschichte, die man sich immer außen vor, ob der nun gut ist oder wie der sich installiert oder so weiter. Meine Frage ist halt, das Ding heißt der Bundestrojaner und entsprechend sollte er ja eigentlich dann auf dem Bundesgebiet auch funktionieren. Nur sind ja die Computer eher international ausgerichtet, auf einer Hardware usw. Was wäre dann, wenn sich so ein Ding sozusagen außerhalb unserer Landesgrenzen aktiviert und dann die Daten dort sammelt, ob sich dann die Bundesregierung strafbar machen würde?
Aber der Bundestrojaner hat doch gar keinen Pass.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Da haben wir uns auch schon Gedanken darüber gemacht und sie Frage gestellt. Letztendlich ist es so, dass das im Prinzip nicht verboten ist oder nach dem deutschen Recht zumindest nicht strafbar ist. In dem Sinne aber, die ausländischen Regierungen würden sich das natürlich schon verbitten, wenn ohne diplomatische Abkommen entsprechende Maßnahmen stattfinden.
Also, ja, das heißt, wenn jetzt meine Freunde, die ich im Ausland so habe, England, Polen, was weiß ich was, wenn die dann durch meinen Rechner, der dann, ich bin ja ein Bundesbürger, der vielleicht mal abgehört werden muss, wenn die dann quasi durch mich an so ein Ding gelangen, wen verklagen die dann? Verklagen die dann mich oder verklagen die die Bundesregierung? Das sind so Sachen, die finde ich bei der ganzen Diskussion, abgesehen davon, dass die Polizei sowieso völlig inkompetent reagiert auf Sachfragen, wenn man irgendwelche Probleme hat mit irgendwelchen virtuellen Straftaten. Wer wäre dann überhaupt Ansprechpartner für solche Probleme, wenn jetzt ein ausländischer Bürger von diesem Ding betroffen wäre und dann das Ding ja irgendwelche Schaden anrichtet?
Das passiert ja laut BKA nicht. Ja, also kannst du halt die Frage mal stellen, deinem Bundestagsabgeordneten zum Beispiel per E-Mail. Frag ihn einfach mal, wie das ist.
Muss ich da den Bundestagsabgeordneten fragen oder muss ich den Datenschutz?
Nein, nein, nein, der ist immer dein Bundestagsabgeordneter, der zuständig ist für deinen Wahlkreis. Der ist immer der erste Ansprechpartner für sowas.
Naja, dass der keine Ahnung hat, das weiß ich schon, weil der, das ist der, der, der, der will hier den einzigen grünen Bezirk für sich sein. Und der Herr Ströbele, der hat sich schon bei Kinderfragen, hat er sich schon als völlig inkompetent auch bewiesen und da ist halt ein bisschen die Frage, das beweist sich halt immer wieder, dass sowohl die Politiker als auch die Polizei eigentlich völlig gar keinen Plan haben. Und ja, ich frage mich halt überhaupt, ob das nicht eigentlich ein riesen Propagandading ist, was eigentlich nur nach außen wirken soll. So, ihr Leute, benimmt euch mal im Internet.
Nee, nee, also man sollte die Maßnahme eigentlich nicht als Propaganda hinstellen. Denn der eigentliche Grund für diese Online-Durchsuchung liegt ganz sicher in der Festplattenverschlüsselung. Es gibt halt immer mehr Leute, die ihre Festplatte verschlüsseln und eine normale Beschlagnahme eines Rechners läuft damit ins Leere. Weil man niemand dazu zwingen kann, ein Passwort rauszugeben für diese Festplattenverschlüsselung. Entsprechend ist hier ein Problem. Und die Ermittler argumentieren auch immer wieder, und auch der Bundesinnenminister hat es erklärt, dass sie Schritt halten wollen und quasi nur bevor diese Festplatte verschlüsselt wird oder wenn sie, also wenn die gerade freigegeben ist, darauf zugreifen wollen. Sie haben schon technisch gute Gründe.
Aber der Torianer würde doch mitverschlüsselt werden. Also ist mir nicht ganz schlüssig, wie er aus einem verschlüsselten System raus telefonieren kann.
Na man muss sich ja vorstellen, dass zum einen nicht immer die komplette Festplatte verschlüsselt ist, sondern teilweise auch nur Teile. Und wenn sich das Chartprogramm auf diesem Rechner installiert, soll es ja eine eigene koptografische Routine haben, sodass es sich selbst quasi verschlüsselt und auch die ausgehenden Daten. Und es wird natürlich nicht betroffen sein von normalen Festplattenverschlüsseln. Sie werden schon versuchen, Herr dieses Programmes zu bleiben. Sie wollen aber ran an die Passwörter für die Festplattenverschlüsseln. Nee, sie sagen, sie geben natürlich irgendwie, alle sagen ja, dass Windows-Systeme sehr viel einfacher von so einem Spionageprogramm übernommen werden können. Aber sie sagen schon, dass sie im Prinzip durch eine gute Vorfeldanalyse für alle Betriebssysteme könnten. Und natürlich ist auch klar, dass alle Betriebssysteme Sicherheitslücken haben, die man ausnutzen kann. Es kommt darauf an, wie viel Sachverstand die Ermittler haben. Also wir gehen schon davon aus, dass sie sich zunächst mal dafür beschränken werden. Einfach mangels Know-how.
Ich würde dir ganz gerne einen Tipp abgeben, weil das Mac OS X ist nicht nur ein nicht-deutsches Programm, ein nicht-deutsches Betriebssystem mit deutscher Sprache, sondern es weist jeden Benutzer darauf hin, wenn auf Systemdateien zugesoffen wird und was installiert wird.
Aber unser tolles BKA hat bestimmt auch dafür eine Lösung gefunden, das zu umgehen.
Also zumindest eine OS X mit drin seit sechs Jahren bestimmt.
Das waren deine Fragen, die wurden beantwortet.
Danke schön.
Danke Frank. Aber auf die Minute. Chaos Radio Teil 127 heute zu Gast der Chaos Computer Club. Wir wollten eigentlich über Biometrie reden. Das wird aufgrund der aktuellen Ereignisse um den Bundestrojaner auf die Sendung Ende September verschoben. Wir hoffen auf euer Verständnis und ihr könnt mit dem Chaos Computer Club alle Fragen zum Thema Bundestrojaner klären unter 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste ist Florian, aber vorher Cherry Ghost. August. Auch für alle, die jetzt noch eingeschaltet haben. Wir reden über den Bundestrojaner, die Spionage Software vom Bundesinnenministerium mit Hilfe derer Computer von Privatmenschen beziehungsweise wie wir es auch mitbekommen haben, auch natürlich von Geschäftsleuten oder sonstigen, also jeglicher Rechner, überwacht, ausspioniert und nachkontrolliert werden kann.
Und nicht nur Rechner, sondern wir wissen ja auch, Faxgeräte, digitale Anrufbeantworter, Handys, jede Art von informationstechnischem System wie Ihre Bundesregierung.
Auch, denn quasi übermorgen auf der IFA angucken kann, wie sowas funktioniert. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Anfang des Jahres gab es das Gesetz, also bzw. den Beschluss über das Gesetz. Dann wurde gesagt, ja, wir sind Trojaner, wir gucken erstmal, was da passiert, und heute kam raus, das Ding gibt es zumindest in Grundzügen, es soll wohl funktionieren. Und es gibt schon einige Details dazu. Dazu gibt es ein Papier mit vielen Fragen und Antworten. Es wurde heute veröffentlicht und sorgt für eine Menge Wirbel. Der Chaos Computer Club konnte sich heute vor Anfragen kaum retten. Deswegen ist es umso schöner, dass wir euch beide hier für eine Weile zu Gast haben, damit ihr eure Fragen beantwortet unter 0331 77 97 110. Zum Beispiel die von Florian aus Neukölln. Nament Florian.
Ja, also nachdem sehr viel Negatives über den Bundestrojaner gesagt wurde, möchte ich doch mal ein bisschen eine Gegenposition vielleicht dazu einnehmen.
Wir warten schon eine ganze Zeit drauf.
Ich habe mir nämlich mal so vier Sachen glaube ich überlegt, die eigentlich ganz gut an den Bundestrojaner sind, die man vielleicht mal herausstellen sollte. Einerseits ziehen wir vielleicht überhaupt, ziehen wir denn die richtigen Schlüsse aus allen dem, was schon heute gesagt wurde. Es hieß ja zum Beispiel, spioniert wird sowieso von den bösen Leuten, von den Chinesen oder von den Amerikanern in Deutschland.
Dass das die bösen Leute sind, habe ich nicht gesagt.
Na gut, das habe ich jetzt einfach mal so gesagt. Also oder auch halt von bösen privaten Individuen. Also wer es will, kann es einfach machen. Und der Bundestrojaner würde ja derzeit noch eingesetzt, nach zumindest rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien noch, ich weiß, da kommen bestimmt gleich die Gegenargumente für.
Nein, nein, lass uns erstmal die vier Argumente hören. Also wir wollen dich da gar nicht...
Also, ich spiele jetzt jetzt sowieso. Warum die Bohnen? Dann, wenn ich jemandem Beweise unterschieben möchte, dann versuche ich dem doch quasi einen Rauchen im Kold unterzuschieben. Und so ein Bundestrojaner, da bekommt man ja eigentlich nichts, wo wirklich handfest ist. Da bekommt man ein paar Dateien, da kann man sich irgendwelche Dokumente oder irgendwelche Konversationen vielleicht rausziehen. Aber wenn ich jemandem wirklich was unterschieben wollte, dann nehme ich doch nicht einen Bundestrojaner dafür. Also das ist eigentlich, da gibt es bessere Möglichkeiten für, dem was unterzuschieben.
Zum Beispiel?
Na, indem man einfach was in der Wohnung platziert.
Oder muss er aber da einbrechen.
Naja, das muss man eventuell für die Platzierung des Bundestrojans ja auch.
Aber nicht physisch. Achso, du meinst, dass jemand in die Wohnung einbricht, mit einem USB-Stick oder einer CD in den Regen schiebt?
Oder einen Keylogger in die Tastatur einbaut und den später wieder abholt. Das sind ja auch mögliche Szenarien für die Anbringung. Also der ist vielleicht gar kein guter Rauchener Colt. Dann ist es vielleicht auch ganz positiv, dass das Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen wird, überhaupt durch den Bundestrainer, dass das EDV-Spionage stattfindet. Das heißt, dass das erstmal richtig bei den Leuten überhaupt ankommt. EDV-Sicherheit, dass das Bewusstsein für EDV-Sicherheit dadurch vielleicht gesteigert wird.
Ach ja, naja, mir persönlich haben da die chinesischen Trojaner-Angriffe zur Bewusstseinsbildung schon gereicht. Aber okay, ist das das dritte Argument, verstehe.
Aber ich glaub, das war erstmal schon...
Ich muss sagen, dass ich dein erstes Argument in Bezug auf die, du hast ja gesagt, ob wir die richtigen Schüsse ziehen.
Na ja, man kann jetzt leicht behaupten, der wurde eingesetzt, um politisch engagierte Menschen zu verfolgen. Ist ja nicht so. De facto wollen sie ihn ja erstmal einsetzen, um tatsächlich Verbrechen aufzuklären oder vielleicht zu verhindern.
Oder präventiv, also abzuwehren.
Zum Beispiel abzuwehren. So zum Beispiel auch hier die Verhaftung von dem Soziologen, die passiert ist, die ist ja wohl nicht einfach so passiert, sondern der wurde auch eine Zeit lang überwacht.
Ja und zwar vereinrohren, alle Möglichkeiten, die sie haben.
Und wurde dann in Untersuchungshaft gesteckt. Und jetzt wage ich ja einfach mal die These aufzustellen. Wenn die jetzt in dem Jahr, dass sie ihn überwacht haben, gar nichts gefunden hätten, hätten sie ihn dann einfach so habsnehmen können.
Naja, ist ja mittlerweile A, wieder entlassen. Und es ist ja so, dass... Und das ist doch das Argument von Monika Harms, der Generalbundesanwältin, die auch sagt, ja, ja, also wir hätten ja diese Hausbesuchung gar nicht machen können, wenn wir nicht was Handfestes hätten. Leider können wir es aber nicht sagen, was wir handfestes haben. Also wir werden warten müssen.
Und es gab ja immerhin die wissenschaftlichen Artikel, wo dieser bestimmten Begriff vorkam.
Begründet wird es ja damit, dass er also quasi Gedanken gut vorbereitet hätte und selbe Begriffe wie später in den Bekennerschreiben verwendet hätte in seiner wissenschaftlichen Arbeit und sich zusätzlich mit einem von den Menschen mal physisch getroffen hat.
Für alle, die nicht im Thema sind, was war das für eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit?
Der ist halt Soziologe und hat halt zu dem Bereich publiziert, mir sind die Arbeiten jetzt nicht bekannt.
Es geht um allgemeine gesellschaftskritische Ansätze.
Ja, also es ist nur so, dass er offenbar sich verdächtlich gemacht hat. Und an sich ist es ja grundsätzlich erstmal nichts Falsches, wenn man jemanden, der verdächtig ist, mal auf den Zahn fühlt an sich.
Also wenn man ganz kurz im Sprachbrot, also ob jemand verdächtigt wird oder ob sich jemand verdächtigt macht, ist ja vom Sprachlichen her schon nochmal ein ganz erheblicher Unterschied.
Wichtig ist ja, was du damit eigentlich meinst. Meinst du, das ist schon okay, wenn der so komische Papiere schreibt, dass sie mal seine Telefongespräche über Monate abhören, seinen Internetverkehr abhören und dann seine Wohnung besuchen und ihn verhaften? Willst du das sagen?
Ich möchte das schon so sagen, ja. Weil, gut, ich weiß, ob in dem speziellen Fall, ob das jetzt gerechtfertigt ist oder nicht, sei mal so dahingestellt. Aber im Grundsätzlichen, wenn zum Beispiel mal ein anderes Beispiel. Es hieß doch, dass die Anschläge vom 9.11. es gab da halt Hinweise, dass da was passieren könnte. Und wir sagen noch alle, hey, warum haben die nichts getan? Und wenn wir jetzt, wir wissen zum Beispiel, es gibt Gefährder in Deutschland und die sind verdächtig. Und die planen einen Anschlag und der wird dann durchgeführt. Dann werden wir hinterher auch sagen, hey, ihr habt das gewusst, warum habt ihr die nicht überwacht?
Warum habt ihr nichts getan? Du hast dir aber ein denkbar schlechtes Beispiel gesucht, weil ja seit Monaten bekannt ist, dass die gesamte Zelle, die in Deutschland aktiv war und Mohamed Atta sehr intensiv vom Verfassungsschutz observiert wurde und auch bekannt war. Also das ist jetzt auch die Argumentation, die du bringst, als wenn sie nur mit der Online-Durchsuchung erfolgreich sein können. Man muss einfach mal das Instrumentarium sehen, was die Geheimdienste und die Ermittler ohnehin schon haben. Sie schmorchen eh an allen Telefonen, die sie gerne wollen und hören Internetverbindung ab. Sie können dich geografisch lokalisieren. Sie können mittlerweile eine Kennzeichenerkennung an den Autobahnen machen. Sie tracken dich jetzt auch biometrisch. What else? Also die Online-Durchsuchung ist ja nur noch mal das Krönchen auf dieser Möglichkeit. Es ist ja nicht so, dass heute die Ermittler in den Büros sind und Däumchen drehen und nichts können.
Ja, genau, das ist vielleicht ganz richtig. Das ist einfach nur noch eine weitere Maßnahme. Und deswegen ist es vielleicht gar nicht gerechtfertigt, den Bundestrojaner jetzt so besonders hervorzuheben. Man muss ihn einfach nur als eine weitere mögliche Maßnahme betrachten.
Naja, es gibt ja einen Grund, warum der so hervorgehoben wird. Und der liegt natürlich in unserer Verfassung. Es gibt halt in dieser Verfassung Ewigkeitsrechte. Das heißt Rechte, die nicht eingeschränkt werden können. Und das ist unter anderem Artikel 1 die Menschenwürde. Und das Recht auf informationell Selbstbestimmung, nämlich das Recht jedes Bürgers darüber selbst zu bestimmen, was mit den privatesten Daten passiert, hängt halt an Artikel 1 in Verbindung mit Artikel 2. Das sind also Ewigkeitsrechte. Und deshalb ist der Eingriff so besonders stark. Weil gerade die jüngere Generation hat natürlich Privat-Teste-Daten auf diesem Rechner. Klar ist auch, dass über das Internet und über die privaten Rechner sehr viel intimste Daten verschoben werden. Filme, Bilder, Kommunikation. Der Eingriff ist halt sehr stark. Deshalb ist die Debatte stark.
Naja, ob die Qualität jetzt wirklich so viel stärker ist, als die einer Überwachung eines Telefonats. Man führt ja auch private Telefonate, in der Hoffnung, dass man nicht überwacht wird.
Aber das ist eine aktuelle Sache. Das heißt, da geht es ja nur um das Telefonat, was da geführt wird. Und nicht deine Arbeit der letzten 10, 20 Jahre durchsuchten, alle privatesten, intimsten Sachen, die nur niemand erzählen würde, sondern die du vielleicht nur in deinem Rechner auf dem Tagebuch geschrieben hast.
Ja, es sei denn, man wird schon seit 10 Jahren telefonüberwacht.
Ah, du kannst sich 10 Jahre telefonüberwacht werden.
Also so ein bisschen hinkt das gerade, Florian.
Also ich verstehe schon deine Argumente. Du sagst, lass uns die Terroristen fangen. Aber ob du nicht vielleicht schon ein bisschen der Propaganda aufgesessen bist damit. Also diese, na, es ist ja ein bisschen auch eine Angst, die geschürt wird. Also, dass hier um und herum überall Terroristen sind, das ist halt auch so ein bisschen geschürt. Das wird halt stark jetzt übertrieben. Also die ist ja fast schon eine Hysterie manchmal.
Was zum zweiten Argument, oder zum dritten Argument von Florian führt, der sagte, vielleicht wird dadurch aber auch eine größeres Bewusstsein dafür geschaffen, dass EDV-Spionage überhaupt möglich ist. Und dass man eben nicht hinter seinem Computer sitzen kann und dort allein in seinem Zimmerchen sitzt und das Gefühl hat, du bist zur Aline und da guckt ja keiner drauf. Dem ist ja nicht so.
Also an sich sollte es so sein und es ist eigentlich der Normalfall, dass ich da alleine sitze und keiner guckt drauf. Und wenn natürlich das allgemeine Gefühl da ist, der Staat überwacht uns ja sowieso ständig, sondern werde ich mich als Bürger auch dem entsprechend verhalten und das ist eine Gesellschaft, wo wir nicht hinwollen.
Man muss auch immer noch mal die Balance im Auge behalten. Selbst wenn es hier in Deutschland drei Zellen von Terroristen gibt, die sonst was für fiese Anschläge planen. Die Frage ist, ob ich aufgrund von so ein paar fehlgeleiteten Menschen, ob ich meine gesamte freiheitliche Gesellschaftsordnung ändern möchte für diese Spinner und ob ich ihnen da nicht eigentlich entgegenarbeite. Man muss einfach sagen, absolute Sicherheit kann es nicht geben. Wenn sich jemand auf irgendeinem Marktplatz oder sonst wo in die Luft springen will, dann wird man es de facto nicht verhindern können, wenn er so ein Ding an der Klatsche hat. Was gebe ich dafür auf und wo ist die richtige Balance? Ich finde, da muss man halt abwägen. Die Online-Durchsuchung ist halt wirklich ein starker Eingriff. Ich sehe auch an den vielen Leuten, die sich jetzt an den CCC wenden oder auch in der Uni bei mir, wie viele Leute sich da einfach Gedanken machen und wie unangenehm und wie derwertig ihnen das Gefühl ist, dass sie überwacht werden, wenn sie dahinsurfen, wo sie eben in ihrer Freizeit hin surfen. Sei es Porn oder sei es Flirt oder so im Netz.
Unter der Frage, wie viel Freiheit ist dir deine Sicherheit wert, wenn du das Gefühl hast, in einem sicheren Staat leben zu wollen. Wie viel von deiner privaten Freiheit möchtest du aufgeben? Das werden wir hier natürlich nicht diskutieren können, aber das sind alles Gedanken, Ansätze, die uns in den nächsten Tagen, Wochen und Monaten weiterhin beschäftigen werden. Dieser Bundestrojaner, um nochmal zum Thema zurückzukommen, dieses Papier, was heute veröffentlicht wurde, bedeutet noch nicht, dass das Ding wirklich jetzt schon unterwegs ist und ich morgen so eine Mail bekomme, wo der dann quasi auf meinem Rechen ist.
Also, nun, der Bundesnachrichtendienst setzt die ein. Es ist auch jetzt klar, in welchem Umfang die Geheimdienste dieses, diesen Bundestrojaner verwenden. Das sind so etwa, etwa sechs bis zehn. Da gibt es jetzt verschiedene Meldungen zu, aber der wird schon eingesetzt. Hier geht es darum, ob auch die normalen Ermittler, also jenseits der Geheimdienste, dieses Tool verwenden dürfen.
Also im Verfassungsschutzgesetz Nordrhein-Westfalen, die haben das Ende letzten Jahres beschlossen und das heißt also, die dürfen den auch einsetzen derzeit nach dem aktuellen Rechtsstand. Also es ist zwar auch eine Klage anhängig, aber solange bis die entschieden ist, dürfen die das.
Florian, dir erstmal vielen Dank für den Anruf. Du siehst, da kommen noch mehr Fragen. Wir hoffen noch mal ein paar von denen zu schaffen. Womit wir bei der nächsten Frage werden, die auch auftauchte vorhin schon mal im Vorgespräch. Was ist, wenn ich jetzt Gefühl habe, ich hab so ein Ding, wie wäre ich denn wieder los?
Na erstmal, man schickt ihn erstmal zu uns, damit wir ihn analysieren können und danach kann man ihn dann loswerden. Also ich darf da vielleicht mal aus diesem einen Satz, aus diesem sehr lustigen Katalog zitieren. Da ist nämlich dann die Frage, was passiert, wenn man keine Internetverbindung hat und wie soll man dann eigentlich diesen Trojaner wieder deinstalliert bekommen?
Also ich hab den auf dem Rechner und dann kappt sich meine Internetleitung und ich kriege ihn nicht raus.
Genau. Und die Antwort ist, durch eine für den Fall der erfolglosen Kontaktaufnahme, also ohne Internetverbindung, mit dem Steuerungssystem eingebaute selbst Deinstallationsroutine entfernt sich das Remote Forensic Software rückstandsfrei vom System.
Das klingt ein bisschen wie so ein Waschmittel.
Ja, also sie glauben echt, sie können da diesen ultimativem Trojaner bauen, der sich auch noch ohne jeden Zweifel selbst installiert, no matter what. Das ist halt schon richtig lustig.
Es ist natürlich schon realistisch, denn ist natürlich das einfachste Mittel, ich klänge meinen Rechner für ein paar Wochen vom Internet ab, dann verbindet er sich nicht mehr mit dem Steuerungsrechner und müsste sich dann theoretisch komplett weginstallieren.
Selbst die Installationsroutine klingt nach Star Trek, oder?
0331 70 97 110. Wir reden über den Bundestrojaner mit dem Chaos Computer Club auf. Fritz, der nächste am Telefon, ist Steffen aus Berlin. Hallo Steffen.
Meine Frage verzahnt sich ein bisschen mit der Frage, die Florian auch gestellt hat. Ich bin ein Anhänger dieses Argumentes, dass ich sage, wer sich nicht zu Schulden kommen lässt. Der hat auch nichts zu befürchten, wenn sich da Trojaner, egal von wem, auf seinem Rechner verzahnen. Das heißt, wenn ich als privater User eben, wenn tatsächlich jemand meine Daten ausspäht, ist es nicht jeder so ein Fachmann oder Fachloch, Fachmann wie die Leute, die jetzt vorher vor mir schon angerufen haben. Ich trete mich nicht zu diesen Fachleuten. Das heißt, ich wüsste nicht mal, wenn ich meinen Firewall, die habe ich veraktiviert, der erkennt auch Trojaner. Aber gut, dann klicke ich auf Deinstallieren und gut ist. Aber ganz offen, wenn er da drauf laufen würde, ich merke es nicht und die, die forsten meine Daten durch, gut, dann forsten sie sie eben durch, wenn ich mir aber nicht zu Schulden kommen lasse. Siehe ich nicht ein, warum nicht jemand auf meinem Rechner zugreifen sollte. Jetzt sagtest du selbst vorhin, den absoluten Schutz gibt es nicht. Siehe aber London, die Anschläge in der Innenstadt. Jetzt sagtest du, das ist noch der Motto, wenn es drei Kranke in Deutschland gibt und die planen Anschläge. Wenn ich aber ein Opfer dieses Anschlages werde, sehe ich die Sache vielleicht ganz anders. Wenn ich jetzt nämlich Opfer in London gewesen wäre oder ein Familienangehöriger von mir, würde ich die Sache mit den Online-Besuchern wahrscheinlich anders sehen. Ich würde es nämlich etwas stringenter sehen. Deswegen bin ich durchaus der Meinung, wenn das eine zusätzliche Maßnahme ist, um die Leute, die krank im Kopf sind, die solche Sachen planen, etwas enger zu schmüren, dann sehe ich durchaus kein Problem darin, solche Sachen zuzulassen. Ich weiß, dass das ein Totschlag-Argument ist, nach dem Motto, wer sich nicht zu Schulden kommen lässt, der gut, der kann es nicht.
Es ist überhaupt kein Totschlag-Argument. Ich finde das Argument von deiner Seite absolut berechtigt, weil ich habe auf meinem Computer auch weder irgendeine Bombe gebaut, noch sonst irgendwas gemacht. Also von mir aus, guck da drauf, du wirst sowieso nichts finden. Aber eigentlich möchte ich sowas nicht.
Selbst wenn ich da jetzt Pornos drauf habe oder Bilder aus meinem letzten Urlaub, dann gucken die sie sich an, aber die sind ja nicht, meine Bilder aus meinem letzten Urlaub sind ja nicht terrorverdächtig, dann gucken die sich an, stellen fest, aha, der hat keinen Dreck am Stecken, dann lassen sie mich wieder, sag ich mal, gehen oder machen keine weiteren Besuchungen.
Das ist ja schon im Prinzip fast die Umkehrung der Unschuldvermutung. Das heißt so hier bitte, ihr könnt ja gucken, ich hab nichts auf meinem Rechner.
Dann heißt es auch praktisch, sie können bei allem gucken und dann finden sie halt so ein bisschen wie im Minority Report, ja. Sie finden dann alle die, die auf ihrem Rechner schon böse Gedanken notiert haben und die ehrlichen Bürger, die machen einen neuen Start. Das ist halt eine Vision von Welt, die ich nicht möchte. Ich möchte auf meinem Rechner, selbst wenn ich Bock hab, schreiben, was ich möchte und möchte mich nicht deshalb zu einem Verdächtigen machen und ich möchte mich auch noch mit den Leuten und seien sie noch so politisch-kritisch treffen können, ohne dass ich plötzlich ins Visier der Ermittler gerate, nur weil ich mit den falschen Leuten telefoniere.
Du machst dich doch nicht verdächtig dadurch, dass du irgendwas auf deinem Computer tippst, was für dich privat vielleicht oder nach dem Motto Meinungsfreiheit, du kannst ja tippen, was du möchtest, wenn du dich nicht verdächtig machst. Aber wenn du dann irgendwann krank im Kopf wirst und du planst tatsächlich einen Anschlag, warum sollte der Staat nicht das Recht haben, auf deinem Rechner zuzugreifen und dich schon ausfindig zu machen und dich zu observieren, um dann, wenn du wirklich zuschlagen möchtest, das dann zu unterbinden?
Weil ich frei bin, zu denken, was ich möchte. Selbst wenn ich mir das überlege und mir konkrete Pläne mache, wenn ich sie in die umsetze, ist das nicht strafbar. Ich darf denken, was ich möchte. Und wenn ich in meinem Tagebuch schreibe, oh, der Schäuble, dem sollten sie den rechten Finger abhacken. Und in meinem Tagebuch schreibe auf meine Festplatte. Dann kann ich das einfach machen.
Dann bin ich aber noch nicht terrorverdächtig. Das ist ja ein bisschen sehr, sehr stark verallgemeiner. Wenn ich in meinem Tagebuch schreibe, der Schäuble ist doof. Und morgen überlege ich mir, ob ich ihn umbringe. Da kommt ja nicht der BND und köffst dann meine Tür und nimmt mich dann fest und sperrt mich für 10 Jahre weg. Das ist doch Quark.
Ja gut, aber du musst ja einfach überlegen, du kannst so eine Gesellschaft nicht komplett gedanklich voll überwachen. Das ist einfach nicht drinnen. Und wenn, dann ist es eine Gesellschaft, da träumen wir noch nicht mal von.
Man muss doch vor allen Dingen mal an den Missbrauch denken. Denk mal an die Fälle von Murat Kurnas und Al Masri. Zwei offensichtlich Unschuldige, die einfach aufgrund von solchen Daten weggesperrt wurden. Und zwar für Jahre. Also es gibt ja auch noch, man muss noch mal sehen.
Auf der schwarzen Seite, ja das ist richtig. Auf der anderen Seite sehe ich...
Aber kann dich natürlich nicht betreffen, nicht wahr?
Nein, na gut. Okay, wenn ich jetzt Murat Kurnas wäre, oder was auch immer, und ich sitze 10 Jahre hinter Gheddan, ist das scheiße. Wenn ich aber, jetzt muss ich mal anders argumentieren, was ihr vielleicht nicht so gerne hört, wenn ich damit aber 100 oder 1000 Menschenleben rette, die am Anschlag dadurch entgangen sind, wenn ich eben drei Murat Kurnas verhafte, und einer von diesen Murat Kurnas hat tatsächlich was am Dreck am Stecken gehabt, und ich rette damit 1000 Menschenleben, Es ist diese Luftsicherheitsgesetzdebatte, ob man also dieses Flugzeug abschließen kann, wenn man andere rettet, da gibt es ja bereits eine Entscheidung vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, und hier ist ganz klar die ethische Abwägung, dass man nicht diese Leute abschließen kann.
Und zwar deshalb nicht, weil man nämlich in die Zukunft nicht sehen kann. Und was tatsächlich passiert wäre, ist halt nicht klar. Und man kann nicht präventiv diese Leben zerstören für die anderen, die man eventuell in der Zukunft rettet. Es ist eine interessante Debatte, aber sie ist halt, wir müssen die abkürzen jetzt, weil wir haben noch so viele Fragen.
Aber auch die Aspekte sind sehr interessant in dieser Diskussion, weil sie natürlich mal von der anderen Seite kommen. Deswegen, Stefan, dir vielen Dank. 0331 70 97 110. Nächste am Telefon ist Felix aus Berlin. Hallo Felix.
Na, ich wollte hier mal ein paar Details fallen lassen.
Lass mal die Details fallen.
Genau, also erstes Detail, Uhr umstellen reicht nicht. In den PDFs ist das eine der Fragen, was dann passiert, wenn die Systemzahlen ungenäutig sind.
Nein, du musstet etwas langsamer klären.
Langsamer und wir müssen mal vom Anfang an.
Ich kläre das ganz langsam. Also am Anfang meinte Frank, man könnte vielleicht den Trojaner loswerden, indem man die Systemuhr vorstellt.
Also das mein Computer sagt, heute ist nicht Dienstag, sondern Freitag.
Ja, also das ist ja eine Sache, die diverse Leute gerne tun, um irgendwelche Software, die nur bis Datum so und so läuft, zu machen. Das heißt, die Frage stellt sich eigentlich aus deren Sicht andersrum, was, wenn jemand immer die Zeit auf den selben Tag zurückstellt, damit irgendeine Shareware weiterläuft. So haben die das gedacht. Und was die sich überlegt haben, ist, dass sie ein zweites Modul in der Software haben, der die Zeit zählt, die diese Software schon läuft. Das heißt, wenn sich das Datum nicht ändert, dann wird das die zweite Zelle zurückgegriffen. Und die Idee dahinter wäre, dass man die Systemzeit vorstellen kann und es wirkt nicht. Aber auf der anderen Seite sagt das Gesetz auch, keine Maßnahme darf länger als drei Monate laufen. Und das heißt, die Sache, die ich vielleicht noch am ehesten denken würde, die man mal probieren könnte, danke an Starbucks übrigens für die Idee, dass man da die Systemuhr vorstellt und dann den Rechner ausmacht. Und die Uhr stellt man halt drei Monate vor. Und dann macht man den Rechner wieder an. Und das müsste eigentlich reichen. Aber ich meine, wir haben die Software auch noch nicht gesehen.
Kann auch aber einfach sein, dass sie sich aus dem Internet eine Zeit holen von einem Zeitserver irgendwo.
Ja, das machen sie nicht. Sie haben gesagt, sie machen keine Verbindung nach außen, weil man das daran detekten könnte, dass der Trojaner zerlässt.
Nee, nee, nee. In dem Fragenkatalog sind das schon spezifischere Antworten. Sie sagen schon, dass sie auch Dateien übertragen werden. Aber sie versuchen halt die Datenmenge zu minimieren.
Sie versuchen es vor allem dann zu machen, wenn du gerade eh auf das Internet zugreifst. Aber ich meine, der NTP, das ist auch eine extra Frage irgendwo, ob sie auf Zeitserver zugreifen, um sie zu synchronisieren. Sie haben gesagt, nein. Ihre Lösung ist, dass sie die laufenden Sekunden, die die Software schon läuft, zählen und dabei die Erweiterung nutzen.
Da kannst du ja vielleicht noch was dazu sagen, wie es dann wäre, wenn ich im Zuge eines Backups diesen Bundestrojaner mir auf eine externe Festplatte als Backup hole.
Genau, das hat auch jemand gefragt in den PDF-Katalog, was dann wäre, wenn man ein Backup einspielt und der Trojaner sollte sich schon deinstalliert haben und dann kommen sie halt auch damit, dass der so ein Timeout drin hat und sich praktisch selbst deinstalliert, wenn zu viel Zeit vergangen ist.
Also für mich quasi als technischen Halblein heißt das, dass so ein Ding ähnlich wie quasi eine kleine Taschenuhr dabei hat und schon zählt, wie lange er läuft und damit eigentlich relativ egal ist, wie lange der Rechner an ist.
Genau.
Alles klar. Oh, den hab ich verstanden. Danke Felix.
Dann schliegt vorhin jemand vor, man soll virtuell Maschinen benutzen, das reicht leider auch nicht. Denn also ein Detail in den PDFs, was ich relativ bemerkenswert finde, ist auch, dass sie gesagt haben, sie wollen im Zweifelsfall auch mal einbrechen und den Trojaner installieren. Also das heißt, sie wollen nicht nur über Internet den installieren, sagen wir E-Mail oder so, was jetzt immer durch die Presse gegangen ist, sondern in dem PDF steht sogar drin, sie wollen erst mal verdeckt einbrechen, also eine Hausdurchsuchung machen, um die Umgebung abzuklären, also um rauszufinden, welche Windows-Version überhaupt darauf läuft. Ja, und dann sagen sie aber auch, das war jetzt nicht in den PDFs, das war eine Frage im Internet, aber sie würden dann auch durchaus eine Hausdurchsuchung machen, um den Trojaner auf dem Rechner zu installieren. Und da geht man natürlich die virtuellen Maschinen mit. Also jetzt eine VMA-Aussetzung zum Surfen reicht auch nicht.
Das heißt also, der Tipp, den die Datenschutzbeauftragten heute gegeben haben, oder von gestern, dass man einfach noch einen zweiten Rechner nimmt, der dann quasi nicht am Internet verbunden ist, sondern komplett 100 Prozent offline, der würde dann eigentlich auch nichts bringen, weil dann kommen sie einmal installieren diesen Trojaner und kommen dann nochmal und holen die Daten wieder ab.
Ja, also online bezieht sich gar nicht so auf Internet, sondern online bezieht sich darauf, dass der Rechner weiter läuft.
Das heißt also, wenn ich jetzt quasi einen Computer habe, auf dem meine Urlaubsfotos und der ganze Kram drauf ist, und das Ding war nie am Internet, sondern steht nur bei mir zu Hause rum, nützt mir das auch nichts?
Na dann könnten die trotzdem bei dir einbrechen und den Trojaner installieren und später wiederkommen. Das ist übrigens sowieso eine der Planungen gewesen. Schade, ich hielt das für eine gute Idee. Genau, also eine der Fragen war auch, kommt da nicht viel zu viel Daten zusammen? Und da meinten sie auf der einen Seite, ja, sie würden dann filtern, aber es heißt eben auch, sie könnten auch einfach das als Vorausbestimmung der Daten machen. Das heißt, sie lassen es halt einen Monat laufen, denken sich, naja, jetzt wird ja alle Passwörter abgerüstet haben, und dann machen sie eine offene Durchsuchung. Und dann ist zwar die Platte verschlüsselt, aber sie haben halt das Passwort abgerüstet.
Naja, genau, also und sie reden ja auch explizit dabei auch noch über Keylogger. Keylogger sind Software oder Hardware, in diesem Fall natürlich Software, die Tastatureingaben mitloggt.
Das heißt, wenn ich auf meine Tastatur einen Buchstabencode eingebe, gibt es irgendeine Software, die diesen Buchstabencode weiß?
Genau, oder auch eine Hardware, also es kann auch was sein, was in das Kabel zwischen Tastatur und Rechner eingebaut wird, ein kleines Stück Wasser aus der Stecker. Das merkt man dann nicht unbedingt. Und dann schwupp sind die Passwörter weg.
Die Fälle von bisher dokumentierten Online-Trojanern waren auch tatsächlich Keylogger, die sie in Internetcafés installiert haben. Und zwar durchaus Hardware. Also sie sind hingegangen, haben Tastatur manipuliert und haben dann später hingegangen und haben sich die Daten abgeholt.
Genau, also grundsätzlich nochmal, es geht bei diesem Bundestrojaner, auch wenn der Name noch so schön ist, es geht also wirklich um das ganze Repertoire an elektronischen Angriffen, auch gegen alle möglichen Geräte. Es geht auch selbstverständlich auch um Mobiltelefone. Es geht darum, dass, war ja auch so eine Geschichte, die in den letzten zwei Wochen oder drei Wochen aufgekommen ist, dass auch die Polizei schon gesagt hat, dass sie Mobiltelefone als Wanze benutzen wollen. Das ist eine alte Geschichte, scheint aber tatsächlich aktuell zu sein. Dass also auch selbst wenn das Gerät ausgeschaltet aussieht, dass dann das Telefon von außen angesprochen werden kann und als Wanze benutzt wird.
Felix, jetzt hast du dich ja offenbar ganz intensiv mit diesem Fragenkatalog befasst. Jetzt muss ich dich mal fragen, wie schützt du dich denn gegen den Bundestrojaner?
Ja, nicht ganz klar. Ich denke mal, wenn man Linienungszentrierte ist, ist man im Moment erstmal sicher. Ach, tatsächlich?
Würdest du das unseren Hörern als Ratschlag mitgeben?
Das würde ich unseren Hörern im Moment sagen, ja. Denn was sie bisher gesagt haben, ist alles dieartig. Linienungszentrierte ist man glaube ich erstmal sicher. Im Übrigen geben sie auch selbst zu in ihren Ansagen, dass der Online-Trojaner durchaus Fälle hat, wo er nicht funktionieren kann. Also sie machen erstmal eine Durchsuchung und überwachen ein bisschen und stellen dann fest, oh weia, der setzt was weiß ich FreeBSD ein, irgendwas was sie noch nie gehört haben. Und dann gibt es durchaus das Ergebnis, oh ja, der Online-Trojaner funktioniert nicht und dann gibt es auch noch irgendwie beugerhaft oder so. Also das ist durchaus vorgesehen als Ergebnis der Voruntersuchung, dass der Online-Trojaner nicht anwendbar ist in dem Fall. Und ich denke mal, das bezieht sich im Moment auf alles, was nicht windlos ist, aber das ist natürlich auch nur Vermutung.
Also du fühlst dich sicher. Diese Nachricht geben wir vielleicht unseren Hörern dann mit.
Also Linux allein reicht nicht. Man muss natürlich auch die Platte noch verschlüsseln, aber in der ersten Nährung würde ich sagen, ja.
Dann müssen wir unseren Hörern jetzt empfehlen, freie Betriebssysteme zu benutzen.
Hilft auch nichts gegen Keylogger, ne?
Aber bevor wir jetzt hier Puppendokter-Pille machen und ihr zuhört in der Zeit, wird Keylogger, Linux, freie, Dingsbummsplar, chaosradio.at. CCC.de ist die E-Mail-Adresse oder aber hier klickt fritz.de, die Webseite zum Sender, auf dem ihr gerade das Chaosradio hört, zum Thema Bundestrojaner und da werden wir es irgendwie hinkriegen, eure Fragen und eure Anregungen auch weiter zu leiten, weil wir werden auch nicht alle Leute in diese Sendung kriegen, die Leitungen sind wirklich ziemlich voll. Das heißt, weitere Diskussionen finden auch gerne in den entsprechenden Voranstalt. Jetzt machen wir es in den Nachrichten und danach geht es weiter.
Achtung! Closur muss leider krankheitsbedingt absagen.
Neu dafür auf der Bühne?
Und das hört man gleich drei nach 12.
Tausende Menschen haben angesichts der Waldbrände in Griechenland am Abend gegen das staatliche Krisenmanagement protestiert. Vor dem Parlament in Athen trugen die meisten der rund 8000 Demonstranten schwarze Kleidung, um an die 64 Todesopfer zu erinnern. Den Politikern warfen sie vor jahrzehntelang nicht, gegen Bodenspekulation und Brandstiftung vorgegangen zu sein. In Afghanistan haben die Taliban bis zum Abend zwölf ihrer südkoreanischen Geiseln freigelassen. Für die übrigen sieben endet ihre Geiselnahme wahrscheinlich morgen. Der Freilassung ging eine Zusage der südkoreanischen Regierung voraus. Sie sicherte den Taliban zu, ihre 200 in Afghanistan stationierten Soldaten wie vorgesehen bis Ende des Jahres abzuziehen. Trotz Kritik aller anderen Parteien besteht die Union auf dem Verbleib der letzten US-Atomwaffen in Deutschland. Man könne nicht vollständig auf die nukleare Abschreckung verzichten, sagte der außenpolitische Sprecher der CDU-CSU-Fraktion von Kläden, dem RBB-Magazin Kontraste. Im rheinland-pfälzischen Büchel sollen noch etwa 20 Nuklearbomben lagern. Der Chaos Computer Club zweifelt am technischen Sachverstand von Bundesinnenminister Schäuble. Es stimme natürlich nicht, dass Trojaner nicht entdeckt werden können, sagte ein Sprecher des Computer Clubs einer Zeitung. Schäuble hatte vorgeschlagen, die Computer von Verdächtigen zu durchsuchen, indem man ihnen ein Trojaner mailed. Im Rückspiel der Champions League Qualifikation hat Werder Bremen bei Dynamo Zagreb 3-2 gewonnen. Damit hat Werder die Champions League Gruppenphase erreicht. Auslösung dazu gibt's morgen. In der Nacht locker bewölkt oder klar, es bleibt trocken. Kühlt ganz gut ab auf 9 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es erst mal sonnig, später ziehen von Nordwesten her Regenwolken auf. In der Briegnis und der Okermark kann es dann auch ein paar Schauer geben. Es werden ansonsten allgemein 17 bis 20 Grad. Der Verkehr auf Ritz A12 Berliner Ringenrichtung Frankfurt-Oder. Lkw-Rückstau zwischen Frankfurt-Mitte und der Grenze. Ansonsten keine Störungen, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Heiliger Strosack. Diese Nummer ist so grottenalt, dass man eigentlich denkt, naja hol die hier alter Punk-Kram, aber so scheint doch ziemlich aktuell zu sein. Abwärts der Computerstaat aus dem Jahre 81 oder 82 glaube ich, vom Album Abwärts. Die Jungs sind übrigens wieder zusammenspielen, diese Wochen Konzert im SO36, aber das nur am Rande, denn wir sind hier nicht in der Musiksendung, sondern im Blumen auf Fritz. 0331, 7097, 110, Chaosradio Teil 127 zu Gast sind Constanze und Frank vom Chaos Computer Club. Und wir reden über den Bundestrojaner, denn heute ging durch die Medien, dass das Bundesministerium mehr oder weniger zugegeben hat, dass dieser Bundestrojaner am Start ist, sagt man wohl salopp dazu. Und es gibt einige pikante Details, wie das Ding jetzt konkret funktioniert. Und wenn ihr Fragen dazu habt, wie viele andere Menschen auch, dann ist das die Sendung, in der ihr diese stellen könnt, wie zum Beispiel Armin aus Berlin. Hallo, grüß dich. Deine Frage.
Ja, also ich hab jetzt von dem Freund, bloß von diesen Soziologen gesagt, es soll am Knast geendet sein. Könnt ihr hier das vielleicht nochmal ausführen, was da genau war?
Also ganz kurz, das geht um die, du hast ja wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, dass in Berlin oder im Umkreis von Berlin seit Anfang des Jahres eine ganze Menge Autos brennen. Verdächtigt werden einige Gruppierungen, eine davon ist die militante Gruppe MG. Und im Rahmen dieser Ermittlungen um die Brandstifter ist man auf einen Soziologen gestoßen, André H der kritische Texte schreibt, hinsichtlich Stadtentwicklung, Gesellschaft. Und man hat jetzt, das war sozusagen das I-Tüpfelchen, diese Ermittlungen, hat dann festgestellt, dass er mal Texte publiziert hat, wo anhand von einem Wortvergleich oder wo bestimmte Begriffe, typische Begriffe, also nicht typische, sondern bestimmte Begriffe, auch drin vorkamen, die auch an den Bekenner schreiben, von so einem Brandstift dann vorkamen.
Sie haben vor allen Dingen auch gesagt, die Bekenner schreiben seien intellektuell sehr anspruchsvoll und deshalb könne auch nur ein Wissenschaftler, wie er, der im Wort gewandt ist, überhaupt solche Texte verfasst haben. Also sie werfen auch eine gewisse geistige Urheberschaft davor. Es ist eigentlich schon das Ende vom Lied, also viel mehr haben sie nicht in der Hand, bis auf noch die eine Sache, dass sie sich eben mit einem derjenigen, die sie da festgenommen haben, bei einem Brandanschlag vorher getroffen hat. Also im Prinzip, zumindest was bisher veröffentlicht ist, ist eigentlich die Beweislage sehr gering. Und die Wissenschaftswelt, also vorneweg sogar die internationale Wissenschaftswelt, hat sich hier mit offenen Briefen an die Staatsanwaltschaft gewandt und hat gesagt, okay wir betreiben hier Wissenschaft, wir wollen nicht kriminalisiert werden für unsere Gedanken.
Und der kam dann schon in den Knopf, oder?
Na, der war in Untersuchungshaft und ist dann wieder freigelassen worden. Es kam noch mal zu einer zweiten Wohnungsdurchsuchung bei ihm, wo sie dann die eigenen Protokolle von ihrer ersten Durchsuchung gefunden haben.
Was mich da eigentlich mehr besorgt bei dem Ganzen, und da denke ich auch, das Fabri über den Typen, der in Guantanamo war, ist da nicht wie, kommen die eigentlich an die Information hin, sondern wie verwenden die die? Ich glaube, das ist mehr ein Problem der staatlichen Bildhür, als dass man mich wirklich beschappelt. Also wenn die mir auch auf dem Klo zuschauen, ist mir das relativ egal. Aber wenn die dann irgendwie die Information hernehmen und das dann verdrehen, naja, aber staatliche Willkür ist natürlich ein Problem, das kann man auch schon aus Schriften von vor 2000 Jahren ablesen, dass nicht all die Leute den Kopf verbrochen haben.
Sicher, und also ich denke natürlich schon, dass die angesprochenen Fälle von Al-Masri und Murat Kurnas natürlich Extremfälle sind. Man sollte die auf keinen Fall verallgemeinern, das wollte ich auch damit nicht sagen. Aber die Willkürfrage muss man natürlich stellen, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn es bei dem Bundestrojaner um eine heimliche Maßnahme geht, die hinter dem Rücken passiert. Wo ja normalerweise, wie jetzt an dem Fall von dem Soziologen, über den wir eben gesprochen haben, die Maßnahmen des Staates offen passieren. Hier ist es halt hintenrum. Und diese Heimlichkeit der Maßnahme wird auch so besonders kritisiert.
Wobei, ich muss sagen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob es unbedingt Willkür ist. Aber es ist ja so, dass ich als Beschuldigter auch immer ein Recht habe, mich zu verteidigen. Es gibt gewisse rechtsstaatliche Spielregeln, gewisse Regulatorien. Und im Moment sind die einigermaßen im Gleichgewicht. Das heißt, es gibt irgendwie bei einer Durchsuchung, dann gibt es Protokolle, es gibt Zeugen und so was. Und das sind Sachen, die bei dieser Online-Durchsuchung, bei so einer heimlichen Durchsuchung dann plötzlich nicht mehr im Gleichgewicht sind. Das heißt, dass ich dann keine angemessene Möglichkeit mehr habe, mich zu verteidigen oder entsprechend auch für meine Entlastung wieder zu sorgen.
Wobei, naja, ich wundere mich ein bisschen, dass es dich nicht stört, wenn dich jemand auf dem Klo überwacht.
Wir hatten keine Klotüren, oder? So der 68er.
Ja gut, aber das ist dann quasi persönliche Befindlichkeit, ob man auf dem Klo zugeguckt werden möchte oder nicht. Das gehört doch gar nicht hierher. Der Grundpunkt der Diskussion...
Ich kann mich da nicht verteidigen. Nehmen die dann irgendwelche Informationen vom... Ist jetzt egal, ob übers Internet oder aufs Telefon, die hat dann irgendwelche Informationen und ich darf mich da nicht verteidigen, oder wie?
Dann sind wir ja bei staatlicher Willkür.
Dann ist das Problem eigentlich nicht, dass die mich abhören oder ins Internet mit reingehen oder was auch immer, sondern es ist das Problem einfach staatliche Willkür. Das heißt, meine Grundrechte, das ich mich verteidigen kann, gibt es halt da nicht mehr.
Natürlich, es ist auch die Argumentation der Juristen, dass man sich gegen eine heimliche Maßnahme, von der man nie erfährt, nicht wehren kann und den Rechtsfähigkeit nicht bestreiten kann.
Was einer der Hauptkritikpunkte ist an dieser ganzen Diskussion um den Bundestrojaner, dass du sozusagen nicht einen Brief bekommst oder jemand an deine Tür klopft, sagt, können wir bei ihnen mal gucken, hier ist der Durchsuchbefehl, sondern du kriegst gar nicht mit, wenn irgendjemand deine privaten Sachen durchsucht. Und da ist natürlich der Punkt, dass viele Leute sagen, soweit verlegen wir nicht. Armin, danke dir für den Anruf. Der nächste am Telefon ist Klaus, ebenfalls aus Berlin, mit einer absolut berechtigten Frage. Hallo Klaus.
Erstmal wollte ich mal an der Stelle loswerden. Ich finde das absolut beschissen und ein Eigentor, dass der Blumen nur noch zwei Stunden lang ist, gerade bei so einem Thema, aber es ist eine andere Sache.
Auch das ist was, was wir hier nicht diskutieren können und die sind jetzt zehn Sekunden Redezeit schon weg hier.
Gut, also die eine Sache war mal ganz praktisch. Ich bin nicht der Meinung, also wenn das, was ich weiß über Wohnraumüberwachung, du bist überhaupt nicht berechtigt als Überwachter, ein Überwachungstool oder jedenfalls keine Kamera oder Mikrofonen eigenmäßig zu entfernen, dann macht das keinen Spaß.
Das ist einfach schlicht nicht wahr. Das stimmt nicht.
Also ich denke mal...
Du kannst sie gerne mal nachlesen, das ist gut dokumentiert. Da gibt es ja viele Entscheidungen drüber, das ist nicht wahr.
Na gut, bin ich schon mal beruhigt.
Also solltest du bei dir in der Wohnung eine Kamera haben...
Und solltest du einen Bundestrojaner finden, kannst du ihn wirklich gerne an uns schicken. Du machst dich dabei nicht strafbar.
Du kannst den Pilesend an einem Auto auch gerne öffentlich versteigern.
Genau, oder auch zu uns schicken.
Ja gut, also ich glaube nicht, dass ich einen kriegen werde. Ich habe nämlich sowieso kein Internet im Moment. So, ich wollte eigentlich mal... Also es sind ja so viele Sachen gesagt worden, da haben sich mir die Haare gesträubt von ein paar Anrufer vorher. Da möchte ich erst mal sagen, ich glaube, also bin mir sicher, es geht da überhaupt nicht drum, irgendwelche Terroristen abhaft zu werden. Weil erstens mal, also wer wirklich da in dem Bereich professionell was macht, der wird weder irgendwelche offensichtlichen Dateis in einen Chat rumschreiben, noch auf seiner Festplatte haben. Ja, sondern also die Al-Qaeda-Leute, die haben ja wohl anscheinend mit Handzetteln gearbeitet. Also das macht jeder vernünftige Geheimdienst so. Dann verabredet man irgendwelche unterfänglichen Kennworte. Also glaube einfach, es geht darum, dass man da eher ein Instrument haben will, Leute massenhaft zu kriminalisieren. Und zwar, dass die Leute sich auch dran gewöhnen sollen, dass wirklich, wenn schon einer anruft und sagt, ist mir doch egal, ob die mich beim Scheißen filmen. Also dass man sich dran gewöhnen soll, jede Lebensäußerung muss überwacht werden. Dass jeder im Vorfeld verdächtig ist. Und wer was dagegen hat, der muss Dreck am Stecken haben. Und da möchte ich mal an Sachen, ich meine, das ist zwar nicht mehr modern, aber im Dritten Reich wurde sowas auch gemacht. Da wurden massenhaft Leute registriert und dann hat man die Gesetze geändert. Und was gestern erlaubt war, war plötzlich kriminell. Aber tausende von Leuten haben sich plötzlich auf der Seite befunden, dass sie einfach mal kriminell waren. Dass sie das Land nicht mehr verlassen konnten.
Viele der Traditionen, die sich bei uns gesetzlich herausgebildet haben, insbesondere auch im Verfassungsrecht, sind natürlich genau nach den Erfahrungen im Nationalstilismus geschaffen worden. Und auch um solche schlimmen Exzesse vom Gesetzgeber zukünftig zu verhindern. Natürlich. Niemand sollte vergessen, warum wir diese grundgesetzlichen Garantien haben, damit wir genau in so eine Situation nicht mehr kommen. Ich würde es aber nicht so stark überziehen. Ich würde nicht die aktuellen Regierenden mit den Nazis vergleichen.
Ich meine, es gibt hier Nazis auch in diesem Land, die noch was zu sagen haben. Ich frage mich halt, warum wird es zum Beispiel, wenn man massenhaft sich das Recht rausnehmen will, Leute zu überwachen, warum bringt dieser Staat es nicht fertig, die NPD zu verbieten?
Weil er sich unterwandert ist mit Fauleuten vom Staat.
Na ja gut, aber ich meine, das ist ja immer eine Sache, was für ein politischer Wille da ist. Und ich denke mal einfach, also zum Beispiel der Mensch, der vorhin angerufen hat, von den Londoner Anschlägen da gesprochen. Ich meine, ich finde das überhaupt keine legitime Gegenwehr, in der U-Bahn Bomben zu installieren und irgendwelche Leute im Berufsverkehr da in die Luft zu sprengen. Aber man kann doch nicht massenhaft Leute umbringen wie im Irak. Oder man kann ein Land in die Steinzeit zurückbomben wollen. Das haben sie offiziell gesagt, wollten sie halt in Vietnam machen damals. Haben sie auch versucht, die Kuppel, die laufen da heute noch um. Und dann kann man sich wundern, wenn die Leute irgendwann zurückschlagen. Und dann sagt man ja, wir wollen uns nur verteidigen. Und ich meine, ich denke mal, Leute, die solche Maßnahmen wie Schäuble fordern, die wissen schon ganz genau, warum sie so eine Überwachung vielleicht brauchen könnten in Zukunft. Und das sind auch immer so Dammbrüche, das sind immer Sachen, da werden total übertriebene Forderungen gestellt. Dann kommt das Verfassungsgericht, relativiert das ein bisschen. Aber die Entwicklung läuft doch immer genau in diese Richtung. Also zum Beispiel mit der Autobahn.
Warte mal, Klaus, warte mal. Wir machen jetzt hier ein Fässchen nach dem anderen auf, die auf keinen Fall mehr zu schließen sind in dieser Sendung. Deswegen wirklich bitten, dich da auch kurz zu fassen oder dich zu präzisieren, weil ansonsten kommen wir hier vom Hundertsten ins Tausendste und wir haben noch original 10 Minuten Sendung. Und wie du selber festgestellt hast, dauert der Blumen noch zwei Stunden und damit war es dann vorbei. Also um deine Argumentation ganz kurz zusammenzufassen, sagst du, dass diese Art und Weise der Überwachung, die jetzt mehr oder weniger geplant ist oder in der Pipeline ist, eine Art Dammbruch darstellen könnte. Ich werde genau in diesem Konjunktiv formulieren, ob es soweit ist, können wir alle nicht voraussehen und wir hoffen nicht, dass es soweit kommt.
Wir können doch immer noch hoffen, dass sich das Bundesinnenministerium besinnt und von dieser Ausspionierung mit diesem Trojaner absieht.
Sagen wir mal so, das Dammbruch, das wäre auch so ein Ding, was ich mal erwähnt hätte. Also das kann man eigentlich sagen, dass es andauernd versucht wird. Und gerade seit dem Herrn Schäuble, aber nicht erst seitdem. Und ich habe halt immer das Gefühl, wenn ich auch die Anrufer manchmal höre, es gibt überhaupt kein sowas wie ein demokratisches Bewusstsein, gibt es bei vielen Leuten vielleicht gar nicht mehr. Deswegen werden solche Sachen versucht. Also Autobahnmaut, jetzt wird jeder Pkw das Kennzeichen fotografiert. Anfangs hieß es, wir wollen Gebühren erheben, dann wollten wir Schwerkriminelle fangen. Also das sind einfach Sachen, wo jede Woche was passiert. Wo Leute sagen, ich hab nichts zu verbergen.
Ja, und damit sind wir jetzt, ich fahre jetzt ganz fies dazwischen, damit sind wir bei der Autobahnmaut, da wollten wir eigentlich gar nicht hin. Aber um mit Leuten darüber zu reden, was Demokratie eigentlich ist und was jeder in diesem Staat machen wollen und dürfen kann, dazu machen wir auch Sendungen wie diese. Danke dir für deinen Anruf. Ja, wie gesagt, wir haben noch 10 Minuten, also quasi nicht mal mehr so viel, weil der Night Flight steht auch vor der Tür.
Also wir haben eigentlich noch eine ziemlich wichtige Sache, das geht nämlich um die Benachrichtigungspflicht. Das heißt, wenn bei mir so eine Maßnahme stattgefunden hat, sei es eine Telefonüberwachung, sei es eine heimliche Online-Durchsuchung, was auch immer, dann gibt es immer Regelungen in den Gesetzen, dass der Betroffene benachrichtigt werden soll. Das heißt, lieber Herr, Frau, Sie haben bei Ihnen, hat diese Maßnahme stattgefunden.
Das wird im Nachhinein gemacht.
Das soll im Nachhinein gemacht werden. Und das Problem ist, das steht eigentlich drin, also es müsste eins, aber die Praxis zeigt, dass es häufig immer mal wieder gerne vergessen wird oder aus irgendwelchen taktischen Gründen dann nicht gemacht wird. Und das ist ein ganz, ganz großes Problem bei all diesen Maßnahmen.
Man muss es eigentlich sogar noch krasser formulieren. Es ist eigentlich so, dass nur sehr, sehr wenige von diesen Maßnahmen jemals erfahren, das heißt, die Benachrichtigungspflichten werden eigentlich so gut wie überhaupt nicht erfüllt. Also sind in vielen Bereichen immer nur so 10, 15 Prozent, die jemals erfahren.
Wie ist das Prozedere, wie geht es jetzt eigentlich weiter? Also Anfang des Jahres gab es die Gesetzentscheidung, dass dieser Bundestrojaner installiert oder erfunden werden soll. Heute, seit gestern ist klar, das Ding gibt es. Es funktioniert zumindest in Grundzügen. Jetzt wird des Weiteren drüber diskutiert zwischen SPD und CDU, wie jetzt die konkreten Maßnahmen aussehen sollen. Ab wann ist das Ding einsatzbereit? Wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Ja, also beschleunigt ist es noch nicht, sondern es geht jetzt um dieses BKA-Gesetz, also ein spezielles Gesetz, was dem Bundeskriminalamt bestimmte Befugnisse bei der Terrorabwehr zusprechen soll.
Und präventiv.
Präventiv auch. Und das steht jetzt gerade zur Diskussion. Und die große Frage ist, ob diese Online-Durchsuchung in dieses Gesetz mit reinkommt oder nicht.
Und da umgeht sich auch der Streit innerhalb der Koalition.
Weil die einen sagen, nein, wir wollen es nur als Paket verabschieden. BKA-Gesetz ohne die Online-Durchsuchung macht keinen Sinn. Und die anderen sagen, ne, also wir müssen es jetzt nochmal diskutieren. Da scheint es offensichtlich erheblichen Diskussionsbedarf zu geben. Und lass uns doch erstmal das BKA-Gesetz ohne verabschieden.
Also das ist aber einfach so, dass seit eigentlich seit Wochen das BKA und auch die BMI von seiner Seite sagen, da gibt es nichts zu debattieren. Wir müssen diese Online-Durchsuchung haben. Wenn nicht, verbiegen wir uns auch die Verfassung, falls es nicht grundgesetzkonform ist. Also sie wehren auch diese Debatte ab, die eigentlich ganz wichtig ist, die wir mal brauchen.
Dass es nichts zu debattieren gibt, haben wir in den letzten zwei Stunden gesehen. Wir werden auch nicht mehr alle Anrufe schaffen. Wahrscheinlich noch Björn aus Parchin. Bevor wir mit Björn reden, an euch beiden nochmal die Frage, um es zum Schluss nochmal zu präzisieren, was kann ich machen, welches Gefühl, aber ich hab so ein Ding.
Natürlich, wir brauchen ganz dringend dann diesen Bundestrojaner zum Analyzieren beim CCC. Und danach, ich würde ihn einfach doch eher entfernen, man kann natürlich darüber dann auch gezielte falsche Informationen verbreiten. Also wenn man jetzt weiß, man hat diesen Bundestrojaner, dann kann man ja auch lustige Informationen an die Ermittler geben.
Die Porno-Sammlung, dass ihr auch was zu lachen habt.
Ja, damit die was zu gucken haben. Die Porno-Sammlung, wir haben doch keine Porno-Sammlung auf dem Rechner.
Ihr bringt mich in Teufelsküche vorhin, wenn ihr das CCC erfüllt habt. Nein, Quatsch. Björn aus Parchim, hol uns mal da raus. Hallo Björn.
Ja, was wollte ich dazu sagen? Also mein Statement zu der Sache Bundestrojaner ist, eigentlich, dass es nur das Gründchen ist.
Was sagst du das?
Ich bin in der DDR geboren und verfolge seit Jahren die unrechtbeginnen Diskussionen vom Überwachungsstaat. Und muss ganz ehrlich sagen, nachdem was heute in der demokratischen Gesellschaft abgeht, das ist einfach für mich unfassbar. Also da wird über ein System hergezogen und das heutige ist meiner Meinung nach absolut nicht ein Stück besser. Es ist nur wesentlich subtiler und versteckter, als es früher gewesen ist.
Hast du denn außer dieser Online-Durchsuchung jetzt mal gesehen, was sich noch so in diesem BKA-Gesetzentwurf befindet? Also wie siehst du die anderen Möglichkeiten, die sie jetzt den Ermittlungsbehörden einräumen wollen außerhalb von der Online-Durchsuchung?
Also ich sag mal so, da kann ich auch ganz einfach zu sagen, früher ist es so gewesen, da sind Leute in eine Wohnung eingebrochen und haben irgendwo eine Wanze installiert. Dieses System hat es erfolgreich geschafft, dass jeder Bürger seine Wanze freiwillig bei sich trägt. Das zeigt alleine dieses Beispiel, ich telefoniere mit euch über ein Handy. Man darf auch nicht vergessen, was das gigantische Zusammenspiel ist zwischen Politik, Geheimdiensten und Wirtschaft. Also was haben wir noch für Möglichkeiten?
Die Möglichkeit, die du hast, ist, dass du als mündiger und schlauer Mitglied dieses Landes und dieser Gesellschaft dich darüber informieren kannst, was hier eigentlich alles läuft und dir jegliche Informationen beschaffen kannst um dich über solche Geschichten zu informieren, wo es dann schon eindeutige Unterschiede zum Thema DDR gibt.
Ja gut, aber andererseits macht es uns auch handelsunfähig, wenn ich als Gruppe von fünf Leuten irgendwo stehe und angeregt diskutiere und als verfassungsfeindliche Organisation eingestuft werden kann.
Als Mitglied einer terroristischen Vereinigung meinst du?
Zum Beispiel.
Also ich meine, es ist schon alles ziemlich scharf und ich denke mal einfach, dass der Terrorismus als Vorwand benutzt wird, um da jetzt gewisse Interessen zu verfolgen. Und wenn ich das jetzt so vergleiche System kritisch mal betrachte, dann kann ich nur feststellen, dass das Kind heutzutage einen anderen Namen hat als früher.
Na ja, es gibt einen kleinen Unterschied. Wir können sie abwählen, wir müssen es nur machen.
Ja, aber einer alleine reicht nicht.
Deswegen machen wir auch so eine Sendung hier.
Deswegen, die fünf Freunde, mit denen du diskutiert hast, red doch einfach mal mit denen drüber. Die fünf Freunde, mit denen du diskutiert hast, red doch mal mit denen einfach drüber. Beziehungsweise, und damit sind wir dann beim Abschluss dieser Sendung und kommen nochmal auf den 22. September zu.
Genau, du kannst nämlich auch noch deiner Stimme Gewicht geben und zur Demo kommen, damit wir denen mal zeigen, wie viele wir sind.
22. September, Brandenburger Tor, www.freiheit-angst.de Danke dir Björn, danke Frank, danke Konstanze.
Das war's Chaosradio Teil 127 zum Thema Bundestrojaner. Heute, wie gesagt, ganz aktuell kurzfristig reingeschoben. Das eigentlich geplante Thema, biometrische Datenerfassung und der biometrische Personalausweis, das schieben wir auf die Sendung Ende September. Und die ist wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Ihr könnt den Podcast der Sendung in den nächsten Tagen nochmal nachhören. Und zwar auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Dort gibt es auch ein Wiki und da gibt es ein Forum. Und da kann man Fragen stellen und sich ansonsten auch an den Chaos Computer Club wenden, wenn ihr da weitere Informationen haben möchtet. Hier auf Fritz geht es jetzt weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. Wir sagen Tschüss und werdet nicht zu paranoid. Schlaf schön, ciao.